Oh,
hello sweet bitches.
We're back at it again.
Ah.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by Ting Ting
is what you would call a no bullshit mobile company.
They put bs in the statements that you're supposed to read,
but you know,
and I know that that's fucking offensive.
That's kind of like saying the n word.
All right.
Just some bs.
Stop it.
Just say bullshit and don't say the n word anyway.
Dang.
This thing was probably like,
he's going to say it in her fucking advertising.
Nokia.
No,
no ting.
Goddammit.
He's getting Nokia racist now.
The inward.
Oh,
Nokia.
Okay.
Yeah.
They don't sell no cues.
Well,
they do sell HTC ones.
Here's what Ting is,
ladies and gentlemen.
Ting buys time on sprint,
which is an excellent service,
and then they apply their own rules like no early termination fees,
no canceling,
no bundling,
and you pay for what you use.
Megabytes,
minutes,
text data.
If you have a heavier month,
you just pay a little bit more.
If you have a lighter Monte,
pay less.
It's really simple.
If you don't use your phone much,
you're hardly paid all 98% of people who switch over at Tang save money.
I don't know if that's true,
but that's what it says on their website and they seem like good people.
So I'm going with that shit.
On the website it says,
I gotta be clear.
98% of people would save money with Tang.
It's because they do mobile differently and what they have four phones is the
sweetest android devices available.
Like the phone I'm using,
which is the Samsung Galaxy note three it's fucking awesome.
I that the iPhone looks like a baby toy to me.
How dare you people pretend that to put that thing away.
Barely a phone.
You're as old as I am,
right?
How can you even read that shit?
You'd known you can't read that thing.
She's on it.
Good move.
A galaxy s four is a another one,
sort of a middle ground and another excellent phone.
They have the HTC one,
which is a beautiful phone.
It's fucking really dynamic to it as his speakers on the sides of it.
So the sound from it is fucking excellent.
They have that bigger one to now to the dude just came out with like is it the
mega call it yeah,
Nigga black.
Is that what it is?
It's a huge,
yeah.
Well whatever it is,
it's giant.
That HTC thing HCC makes them bad ass phones.
That Antonopoulos guy who was the bitcoin guy who were,
we have to get back on now.
Now that everybody's dying,
we have to get him back on.
Um,
anyway,
ting is a,
uh,
an excellent mobile service that our friends use.
Chris Ryan use it,
loves it.
Found out about it from this very commercial.
Uh,
no hold customer support.
You can call them at one eight,
five,
five Ting ftw.
That's for the win and Geek Talk.
Do you get it?
Ting ftw one eight five five [inaudible] eight ftw it's easy.
Go to rogan.ting.com
and you can save money $25 on your first ting device when you sign up.
So go to rogan.ting.com and enjoy it.
We're also brought to you by audible.com the Internet's number one source for
audio entertainment.
I'm a huge fan of audible.com way back in the standup days.
Uh,
were audible used to do,
they used to do a thing with a couple of different comics,
uh,
where they would,
have like weekly standup.
They would pay these guys to come up with like five minutes every week.
It didn't really work.
Did you do it?
Just do it.
This was the pre podcast podcast man really was.
It really was.
And uh,
uh,
I want to say Marmel Marmel did,
I didn't do it.
Talk to me about you.
He's like,
he should have broke into it.
And I was like,
there's not enough room in the company really for that many comedians.
I like I had cleared the decks from me a little more and as you can see it
wildly successful.
It's a good movie.
You have to pay then.
And that was the difference.
They were just a little ahead of their time and nobody had smartphones.
Smartphones,
yeah.
You'd have to put it on like a little Walkman device or something.
He kept saying,
put it on your personal MP3.
It was like,
well why not page me and let me know that you're first of all mps carrier
pigeon,
repeat the show back to you.
But they were ahead of the curve man.
A big total way.
I did it from 2001 to 2005 that'll give you the curve that it was ahead of it.
Cause then podcast started what,
like about a year later,
two years later.
Um,
what time did we start?
We started in 2010 so we started four years ago.
I started the end of 2010.
They were way ahead of the time and that,
that's one of the reasons why their service is so amazing.
They have over 150,000 titles,
books stand up,
comedy specials,
lectures,
uh,
historical lectures.
You can listen to so much.
Cool Shit.
Radio shows are pals.
Opie and Anthony are on there.
It's a,
it's just an awesome service.
And if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book in 30 free days of audible service.
What do we got here?
Back in the UK,
the Sheffield edition.
Oh boy.
Look at that second 90 days.
That's Greg Proops fuckers.
Respect.
Hey those sold at gas stations on cassette.
Oh,
class product.
We were producing,
I was in a gas station once and I bought it on audible one from the old days.
I bought something from Nick Depalo and it turned out nick loves.
Anyway.
Nigga wasn't even getting paid for,
not he got $50 on the night,
but remember there was a whole lot about those cassettes like somebody had
recorded them and just started selling them.
I was at a gas station once and it,
and then I heard like just soon after I bought it,
you know,
for the ride and just soon after it I heard that nick was suing them.
Hey,
I'd love Nick Depaulo
did it.
Yeah,
he's silly.
He said he did a gas station because everybody had warned.
Thomas had Taylor and one was on sports and the other one's on life.
And I remember going with these,
some of your musings that you fuck you,
man,
I got $200.
You did it like you're literally,
the guy gave me $200 to,
could I take your son and like,
sure.
You
know,
that's funny.
I'm in Cincy.
What do you want from me?
You know?
Yeah,
I'll take it.
What do you got?
200 bucks more than I got it.
Let's go.
Let's run with it.
Can I do my audible jingle that John Dimaggio made up on my show drunk one
night?
Sure.
Uh,
he just goes,
ah,
the bull,
when you don't feel lack read,
that's so perfect.
And that's what audible is.
It's fucking in a nutshell
and the commercial.
Any better than that.
audible.com forward slash Joe,
get a free audio book.
Get 30 free days so far,
don't blow service.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t a human
optimization website.
There's a lot of fuckery involving human optimization,
ladies and gentlemen.
So we try to separate the wheat from the chaff as it were.
A great group that I say that correctly.
Yeah.
That's when I never know as it's coming off with my mouth.
I think it's chaff.
I would say Chaffey than if it was champ because I prefer,
it's like people just say Caribbean or whatever.
You have to
spell it without that red squiggly line.
If my life depended on it,
if you gave me a notebook,
tried to get me to,
it's spelled childhoods,
what we sell it on it are,
we sell a lot of strength and conditioning equipment,
uh,
fitness equipment,
supplements like hemp protein powder and raw cocoa butter and things that we
find.
If you,
you know,
you read literature online about beneficial items,
we just tried to sell what people use on a daily basis that are intimate,
mixed martial arts,
all these crazy crossfit fuckers,
Paleo people,
all these people that are into human optimization,
they're into giving their body good nutrition and working their body out in a
way that's beneficial for functional,
physical strength.
And that's the kind of shit we get involved with.
Um,
it translates directly to sports and that's one of the reasons why I love it so
much.
Things like kettlebells,
battle ropes,
steel clubs,
they're not weapons.
We're not forming an army to fight the apocalypse despite what everything looks
like,
where we're providing with brain supplements to make people smarter,
amps supplements to make them stronger and strength and conditioning equipment.
It looks like weapons.
No,
Greg Proops we're not really planning for the apocalypse.
It's just,
it looks that way.
Well,
it's clever.
Subterfuge.
I'll tell you that.
You had me convinced you guys are planning for the apocalypse.
Clever subterfuge would never make its way out of my mouth.
Somewhere along the line I'd be like,
what's the right way,
right word here.
This girl groups,
I salute you.
This girl followed me on Twitter the other day and she's an ex military girl and
she has a bunch of pictures of her with her little on it.
Uh,
kettlebells,
a little girl.
She's a strong as fuck.
That's the 35 pound kettle bell for a woman.
Unless you're like really fucking strong ex military so she can do it.
I guess so.
Damn.
That's a lot of fucking Wayne.
That's hard to do.
She's strong and shit.
Those kettle bells,
like doing proper exercises and holding up the 35 pound me like that.
That's not easy.
That's like a dude doing a 70.
I left it,
uh,
pipelines.
You did a big glass
window.
Shockingly heavy.
Was it ridiculous?
It looked like a dragon.
I bought that.
Added to the blue hazard level or whatever.
I bought a bond once.
It looks like a fish and I can't move it anywhere.
It's like,
it's beautiful.
Okay.
Touch it.
That alien fish thing.
So beautiful.
Can't move it though.
He can't go near it.
Just scared of it.
You know,
that has to live in your house.
I can,
I'll shake charts or whatever.
Art,
you know,
it's,
it's art,
but it's a,
it's a bond.
It's a giant bomb,
right?
I can't use it as a bond.
You gotta use it as art,
but it's really beautiful.
But I never fucking use it.
I just stare at it and rolled joints on is anyway,
we don't sell joints it odd dotcom yet yet,
but believe me,
when the fucking flood gates open and the aliens land and Bitcoin is how you buy
everything.
We're going to be selling joints like a motherfucker,
but for now we sell hemp protein powder that is non psychoactive and if you have
to pee at work,
if they make you pee in cups to find out if you're doing things with your body
that they don't approve of,
the hemp protein powder will not let you test positive for THC.
It's not,
there's no THC in there.
However,
you should be warned that if you eat a lot of poppy seed bagels,
you will test positive for heroin.
And that's a fact.
I don't have,
I had that happened to a friend.
In fact,
the guy got arrested at Heathrow and he was flying from Heathrow to Abu Dhabi I
believe,
or Dubai,
I think it was Dubai.
And he got arrested because he tested positive for poppies cause he had bagels
on him like he had.
He had a a,
a Bagel with those poppy seeds?
No,
they had some sophisticated drug tests they sent him through.
Like they have these puffer tests.
Do you remember those puff puff,
puff and they find like ions or something in the air.
They would blow air on you and then you'd get out.
Well with him it tested positive for heroin because of the poppy seeds.
Wow.
I don't even know if they use the same test anymore,
but it was a big issue.
This port fuck was in jail for heroin.
Right.
In,
in,
you know,
in a foreign land in a very strict Arab regime.
Has like executed summarily kind of today.
Yeah.
I don't remember what country it was.
So it shouldn't be talking to at school.
I feel like it was a Dubai or Abu Dhabi.
They thought it was heroin smuggler.
Right.
You know,
they thought some crafty fucking European dude.
It's snuck in and was a slinging heroin.
Who's gonna ruin their street?
Their seats.
There's cities.
Did he eventually get settled that it,
that it wasn't,
yes,
I believe so.
But another woman was arrested for having Melatonin.
That's another thing people should be aware of.
Melatonin,
which we also sell at [inaudible] dot com is illegal and a lot of Arab countries
and this woman,
she was an executive for end mall in fact,
and she got detained over there for having fucking Melatonin,
which is a sleep aid.
I'm actually asleep.
It's not really that druggie.
No.
Well your brain produces it.
It's produced in the pineal gland.
Doesn't produce as much as it ought to.
Let's be honest.
You've got to stimulate the nerve a little hang by your ankles,
get one of those,
those uh,
gravity things.
Has there been anything that's negative about Melatonin ever published?
I don't believe so,
but I think they just have very strict laws about what to drug over there.
You know,
so it's an Islamic country.
You're not to drink,
you know,
but you can drink at bars though.
You can drink at bars.
We can't leave the bar.
There's no like you cannot go drunk to this treat.
But I definitely had drinks in an Arab country.
I definitely had drinks in Abu Dhabi and it was definitely illegal,
but there are very clear as to like how you would behave outside of there.
Like you can't just go London event like London.
London is crazy as fuck.
You get drunk in London,
you run out and everybody's hugging everybody or fighting.
You don't piss drunk in the streets and yelling at each other,
calling each other cons and it's a fucking great time.
There's none of that.
And I'll be dogs.
They got that shit locked down.
Everybody's super polite,
very orderly and uh,
they keep an eye on,
on trunk.
People,
even bars.
They don't let you fucking wreck everything.
Oh,
not at all.
No,
no,
no.
You'll go straight to jail.
I don't know how that,
this has anything to do with on it,
but when I was trying to say is don't break Melatonin.
Don't bring on it's Melatonin to a foreign land.
Unless they've sorted that out.
I hope they have.
Melatonin is not a drug.
It's not going to get you high,
but it'll help you fall asleep.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N n I t.
Used the codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
I said,
op,
I didn't even say off,
but you know what I was talking about,
right.
It's sort of context.
It's all in context.
Used the code word Brogan,
Greg Proops whose
experience Joe Rogan podcast,
the lovely and talented artist formerly known as Greg Proops.
Thank you sir.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
Thank you for having me on.
Buddy.
Already turned several phrases that I've never
given a lifetime of thinking clever subterfuge.
That's a wall.
That's an awesome,
that's been used on your show.
No,
never at both of them.
Clever subterfuges such an awesome one too.
It's a two word whammer you know,
it's very rare that you can knock something down like that with two words.
I set you up with the off speed and then I bring in the high hard cheese.
It's true because it's like overused,
but clever with subterfuge is a deadly combination is such a great word.
I don't use it enough.
I like persiflage cause that's just like totally cloaking the issue.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
That'll make people not sure whether I agree with you because if they get in any
sort of an argument with you,
it would be revealed that they don't truly know the meaning to that word.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's why that one works here in la,
especially if you're in La,
you know that's a,
that's a,
Tamara was talking about how he,
uh,
would do that with Dennis Miller.
Him and his ex wife.
They would make up a word and say it around Dennis Miller.
You know,
it was like just,
it was like when Hemingway went with the spittoon in a by you and he would like,
she,
yeah,
like they're just making things up and he would laugh.
He would laugh at like,
they would make up a fake word.
Yeah.
And they would do it like,
you know,
diamond rare is a buster and we would do it purposely park with them.
That's hilarious.
With fake words.
Right,
right.
You don't want to be the ass hole doesn't know that.
That's like your work and Tata Surest,
Bam.
But he's that a weird thing where people like have an ego vested in knowing
something.
Like you can't know everything.
No.
I always want to ask if,
I don't know though,
like if I don't know a word too much using I'll say I haven't heard that.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Why do people resist that so much?
Cause then like men that don't want to ask for directions is the satellite down
to not so there.
I'd like to say I was more involved in that regard,
but I'm not,
how come you don't ask for directions?
You want to get robbed?
Like to be told what to do.
I don't like don't walk signs like stop signs.
I think that's why people shoot yield signs on the side of the road and meth
areas because people just get tired of the signs bearing down on them all the
time and they,
they gotta plus it's,
you're fighting the power shooting a yield sign,
right?
Oh I'm going to kick this math.
All the signs to shoot.
That's like the saddest song isn't it?
Down.
And that's the one that shot up.
It's like,
why stop fuck you.
I'm not stopping.
I don't want to shoot this side.
Cause what if somebody goes through the stop sign and killed somebody I love.
Yeah.
Alright.
You can shoot the fucking shit out of a yield sign and I'm just going to be
okay.
Fuck you.
Yield yield yourself knowing that you should know how to yield.
You get to it.
One was traffic circles.
Yeah,
you should fucking figure it out.
Everybody working out together now.
No one knows how to.
They have a little roundabouts in west Hollywood.
And uh,
I lived in England and you learn how to work at a roundabout,
but people in La,
I've never quite figured out how,
what they're commonplace in the east coast.
I had one right down the street from my house where Dick Doroty,
the famed comic of Boston.
You ever heard of Dick door?
Godfather of Boston.
Oh,
okay.
She's old school dude.
He,
he uh,
used to actually book a lot of rooms too.
I worked for him at times.
He was like the first guy to ever had them mind headlined me.
So I've got a warm spot in my heart for Dick.
He wiped out on one of those loops.
Oh,
just gone through.
Yeah.
I was going through one of those traffic circles and somebody hit him.
Fucked him up too.
Cause he was already,
I believe he was in his least fifties at the time and it was a pretty bad break
and he was laid up in his house like a cast on for quite awhile.
Yikes.
Yeah.
But that's,
cause those traffics are 20 now.
How they work.
They're weird.
You're supposed to let the person go.
That's how it works.
Don't jump in ahead of them.
That's not how it works.
Don't,
don't.
Yeah.
Don't be a dick.
Don't try to like save an extra second and cause death.
Whoever's in the circle,
it's theirs until they get out of the circle.
And that's why,
and you get to go around to get,
if you miss your turn,
that's what makes them a circle.
There's Dick Doroty dig Doroty got probably now.
He was actually in a band.
Yeah,
he's okay.
I mean,
I'm sure his ankles.
Fuck,
it's a bunch of comic clubs.
Yeah,
we always did.
Yeah.
W he was the first guy to ever headlined me.
The first guy that took the first guy to ever give me like real work on the road
and put me in like,
yeah,
you know,
legit clubs.
Dick Doherty's,
comedy hut.
I worked there with Bobby Kelly and Dane Cook when Dane Cook was a part of
Allen,
the monkeys who Dane Cook was a in a,
a troop,
like an Improv troupe with Bobby Kelly.
And they would do sketches and then they would um,
do stand up.
Like they would all do a couple of sketches and then at the end they would eat,
you do individual standup,
but they'd do five minutes each or 10 minutes each or something like that.
And Dane was part of that.
And then Dane and Bobby started doing standup on their own.
And now al lives out here.
He's doing something,
something show Biz related.
I'll a improv group names are awesome.
Uh,
I lived in San Francisco and there was a group there called Papaya juice and
they were the old school guys.
And then,
uh,
our group was called fault line.
Get it.
Cause we were from San Francisco.
Yeah.
That's the kind of shit you have to live down the rest of your life.
But it's like,
Hey man,
we were 20,
you know.
Yeah.
Is that how you got into comedy through uh,
like doing an Improv troupe?
Oh,
I've never seen it.
Yeah,
no.
it is actually.
Yeah.
I was in a group with a bunch of guys in San Francisco,
in a,
a Mike Mcshane was in that group.
I don't know if you know Mike,
he said,
I heard the name actor and he was on his lung and stuff.
And uh,
okay,
that's where it is.
And then,
uh,
we,
um,
then,
then I did stand up after that when we broke up and then we all kind of did our
own thing after that.
But we,
we wrote sketches to,
and we did Improv.
So like we had a show that had sketches and improvident we put it on at a place
in San Francisco at ninth and market.
This isn't an eighties.
And,
um,
yeah.
And then,
you know,
so we had little costumes and shit like that.
And,
Oh yeah,
we wrote songs and everything.
What kind of sketches?
Like what would you do?
Like some of the funnier ones we did one with these two poodles were uh,
uh,
in love,
at the two old ladies are taking two poodles out for a walk and,
and we had,
you know,
they had to wear a little like dog is or whatever and they,
they had this mad French affair.
I remember micro thought one.
Uh,
but we would do political stuff too.
Like we would do a whole is about uh,
uh,
law or I remember we did a Nelson Mandela,
like sesame street sketch that was supposed to be part of a show.
I should think of a funnier one so far.
I don't think I've rocked you with any of the high now.
We used to do a talking heads parody.
That was how we would open the show and I would talk to crazy suit
was to say it's not here.
And it was a,
was he the first guy to rock the giant suit?
I think so.
I think he was right,
yeah.
Have you ever seen the videos of him driving around Manhattan and a bicycle now?
No.
Why does he do that?
He's a bicycle enthusiast.
Yeah.
They actually did a short documentary on it,
on him and his bicycle routes and where he goes,
places that he goes to their bicycle friendly.
He loves getting around on bicycles.
And apparently on the west side there's like a path,
like a big path.
It's just for bikes were joggers and people on Bikes and David Byrne like takes
that to work every day and drives around with fucking cabs and shit.
Earn.
Yeah.
He takes it to concerts.
There's a video of him,
see if you can find it too much,
but okay.
He'll,
he'll get on his bike and go from his apartment to a concert and play and play
from his fucking bike.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's weird band.
So he's a French guy from the twenties living in Manhattan.
He's a Rockstar,
but he loves it.
I mean,
I guess it's probably,
it's good exercise for sure.
It was good.
It looks great.
It looks,
he looks very,
it looks healthy.
Um,
and it's probably fun.
You know,
and I bet walking is fucking boring to him.
Once you do that a lot.
You're on your pike.
He's zipping around.
Walking is a stroll.
Yeah,
bikes are fat and you're also,
you're like writing something,
you know,
like we forget that it's fun to ride a bike.
Like my three year old,
my five year old,
when they get on bikes they're like woo
woo.
We forget that bikes are awesome to ride.
Bikes are fun.
When you first get unlimited freedom cause he means you got nad range now it's
like your car,
you can finally go to the store.
Yeah,
you can get around the neighborhood.
You can go miles.
Yeah,
you can get,
you can go down to the park and do the thing and come back and you would run
into packs of other kids like dogs.
Like why all on bikes bikes.
Everybody nodded.
Looking at into the squirrely.
It was like the,
you know,
the modern day version of people in a horses.
Absolutely.
Riding Hood days.
They would run into each other in the woods and try to figure out if anybody had
beef.
Yeah.
Figure out if you had a fucking sling,
some arrows on a bitch,
but did you see the videos of David Byrne?
We,
uh,
we were playing.
If it's crazy,
he's,
I mean,
he's super dedicated to it.
It's kind of impressive,
you know,
because it is impressive.
It takes cameras with them.
We put the Gopro on and you could watch him go through a Manhattan.
It's like,
wow.
Does he wear a helmet?
Yeah.
There he is.
He wears a helmet.
I guess I could look at one of the other monitors instead of the one behind me.
I'm not very clever.
Oh,
there it is.
Yeah,
I know.
He's still skinny.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
he's in great shape.
He,
he,
you know,
he seems like healthy because of it too.
I mean,
you think about it,
that's a lot of really good exercise.
Riding a bike is great cardio.
It's good for them.
It's just,
it's fucking good exercise.
It's fun.
What would be better at running?
The problem is Tommy's,
a girl has got a great joke about it.
Bikers that think they're fucking cars and they're like,
get in the middle of the street.
You know it's,
it's so true.
There's,
there's that,
there's this,
the relationship with cars.
It's like,
it's,
it's too,
if everybody was on a bike,
it would be awesome.
It'd be great to ride bikes,
but everybody's not on a bike.
There's a lot of these assholes,
these giant metal boxes that are texting and when you're on a little bike and
someone's in a giant metal texting box where they looking down every 10 seconds
and a squash,
you like potatoes,
you're going to go fly in at the very least,
something horrible.
I can't ride a bike in la over.
It's not so much that I'm against bikes.
It's the,
I drive just to even driving over here today.
I already experienced the,
I hate living here.
You know the word bum you out so hard because of the way they're driving that
you're like,
did you go to San Francisco?
You would do would fit right in like a glove.
I know,
but that's what I'm saying.
Why can't afford to live there and I'd have to,
I'd have to live in like Belmont,
one of the little suburbs.
I actually looked at real estate when I was in San Francisco.
I was some friends that live up there and I was like,
hmm,
I wonder what I could buy here.
And I was looking at these fucking houses in the city.
There were like $4 million and they were smooshed next to each other.
I mean fucking smushed and you're looking at the house and you like it's,
it's a nice house.
Sure.
But that's not a $4 million house.
You get no yard and the roof work.
Sometimes if you're lucky you had an old ass house and if one of them goes up in
flames,
better hope it's not the one in the bottom right.
Cause if it's on the bottom of the hill the fucking fire goes uphill.
But if it's at the top of the hill,
you might make it here,
let make it,
you might,
they might,
they might be able to soak everything down that's connected to each other.
We have to keep your house moist,
which is easy as San Francisco just let it sit there.
They're usually pretty moist.
Just leave the hose on when you're running.
I mean,
I love it after,
I'd love to have a crib up there.
I should have bought one when I lived there,
but I didn't have any money when I lived there.
When I left.
That would have been a good investment.
And who would've thought that it would become this unbelievable.
Tend to hang out and we thought it was expensive then.
But yeah,
no,
I never thought it would become,
uh,
you know,
toon town or whatever where everything was,
uh,
you know,
everybody's heading off on a little light bus to that little factory making
stuff.
I know.
I didn't think it was going to turn into that.
And then that would be the privileged class.
Do you know anybody who does that?
Do you know anybody who works?
No,
I doubt I would if I had Google glasses,
I would see if I could see them in my mind.
But I don't have Google glass size to have regular glasses,
glasses to book.
I says,
I got to try Google glass way back in the day when it wasn't ready for prime
time and let it was it did it work?
Yeah.
Well I didn't like it.
I think there's something there for sure,
but it's not,
it's a baby.
It's like,
you know,
it's like,
it's like a dual reel recorder for sound.
You don't need that anymore.
You have a phone,
you press the APP on the phone and you can hear everything really clearly.
Yeah.
You know I,
that's what that stupid thing is.
It's just,
it's not ready yet,
but one day there's going to be something weird like that.
Oh,
of course there will.
You Swipe it and you can see things.
You see images in front of you can move them.
You could say Google,
Greg Proops and it'll pull up a wiki on you and you can look at the Wiki.
It's weird,
man.
The navigation thing too is weird.
You're looking at this floating thing in front of your eyeball.
It's telling you where to go.
I didn't like it because I have a phone and I to do all that shit on my phone
and I don't have to be attached to it.
Like a robot.
Like yeah,
I'm not ready to December yacht yet,
but that's the next step.
Right.
And that's why those or do you ever read an author named Dan and banks?
He,
ah,
he passed away last year.
There's Scifi out there.
But to make long story short,
he,
his,
his world that he created what's called the culture and it was basically our
world,
but amplified interest.
Hifi thing were benign nice people who believe in global warming and music and
good times and you know,
shag rugs and whatnot.
My folks,
but all the right,
what Nice White folks.
Now my folks,
my people,
my people.
And then,
uh,
there was another,
force in the universe that was another culture,
but they weren't the,
they were slightly more
primitive and they believed in war and rape and murder and shit like that.
And so the culture,
because they had taught themselves not to be that way anymore.
A thought that it was their duty to empirically lay their values on every other
culture that they ran into.
Wait a minute man.
But in any case that sound familiar?
Yeah,
that's what made it so good.
Yet the computers in it,
uh,
where your friends and spoke to you and sort of rolled with you.
You'd could have one like a pen in your pocket or whatever,
but then also they'd be like next year and be like,
Joe,
what's up?
It'd be like a floating thing and it would age with you and you know,
so you were kind of always on,
you know what I mean?
And if you want to do feel a certain way,
you didn't have to take drugs.
You have all these glands that were already genetically and UC.
It could be like,
I want to be hyper and focused right now and you'd glance some go.
And then like I want to be high and out of it and trip.
I'm going to have some Zang or whatever.
And then you'd mix that with maybe alcohol or something he'd smoked too.
You know,
we're already doing these things.
I know,
but I mean I thought that he,
he is,
uh,
you know,
and if you wanted to change sex,
like say you want to have a baby,
like you're Joe,
but like for a couple of years you want to be a mom and have a baby,
you can change sucks gradually by grounding and then you can have your baby and
then go back to being a man again if you want.
Totally going to happen.
Well that's what I,
I really feel like he anticipated all of these things without,
and also the,
the uh,
liberal fascism of people that have technology at their disposal,
that field that they have a benign view of the world without ever taking into
account.
And which was the,
the crux of all the books.
It's cause they constantly run into other cultures and other cultures still act
like humans here.
Did he write this?
Huh?
What year did he write?
This is all through the nineties and eighties nineties and two thousands.
God,
he nailed it.
That's I think the really good at,
you could read something and one was called the player of games are accessioned
and all these different ones.
It's just the point of view is what makes me laugh.
She's eating and have created a entities to live on.
You don't have to live on a planet.
They've made rings in Spain,
so they had made an asteroid.
And that people can live in those places too.
And the ships are created by minds.
They're no longer created by people in a room,
uh,
mines that are underground,
that are unbelievably advanced.
Think of these things.
And then so when you get in a space ship,
you don't program it her right drive it,
you go,
let's go.
And it goes,
we're off to the something system and it makes all the decisions.
And you know,
I not a highly developed a technology where you're just interacting with it on
that level.
And I have this guy,
Robert Greene on the podcast yesterday and we were talking about what will be
looked at when they look back at this time or our time right now.
What will be looked at?
Preposterous in a preposterous way.
I think these things will like the same way that we looked back at like
Victorian tables,
having clothes on the legs so that people wouldn't get excited.
They would do that.
They would put dresses on legs.
Um,
I think sea world's going to be a meg one.
Seaworld.
Well,
you mean like the idea of having like concentration camps for animals
zoos,
but seaworld specifically because the only argument about zoos is that they're
stupid animals.
It's the only argument.
I don't agree with it,
but it's the only,
the only argument that works.
But that argument doesn't work at all.
When you have these crazy
see people,
which is what dolphins and and an Orca zone and see where I'll just had this
crazy tweet,
man,
I dunno who runs their PR,
but it's the scariest tweet because this is what they say.
They say a study shows that black houses or blackfish black house,
that's the MMA gym.
Black fish is propaganda and that it shows the commensurate death time for wild
orchids and for orchids that live in captivity.
That's their argument that they live the same length as if somehow another
length of life is what's important.
Not the fact that you're in up here in a swimming pool for the rest of your
life.
The fact that they even put that in a tweet is like,
are you guys nuts?
Do you guys really not understand what's going on?
You're,
you're in a prison camp going on.
Those things are like people there like alien people that don't have thumbs,
they can't manipulate their environment,
and so because they can't manipulate their environment,
we somehow or another except them for not being just like us.
They're fucking just like us.
They're just like us.
If you look them in the eyes,
there's a tangible sense that something intelligent is looking at clearly,
clearly,
oh,
and there's,
and look what they've done.
They've,
the persistence is the dinosaur times and they still exist and they've had to
put up with every manner of nonsense from us and shit,
and they could communicate over great distances.
They're sensitive.
They live in packs.
They have fucking of the social hierarchy accents.
They sound different in the north and they do in the south.
I mean they're really understand the concept of motherhood and fealty and all
those things.
Yeah,
there,
watch the truth.
We respect the mother calf bond.
So Wyatt,
you forced them to fucking have incest.
We had a guy on who was a filled dimmers as a trainer and marine land in Canada
and just,
just tell us horrible stories about having to force feed these animals and he's
tweeted pictures of it and how just terrible the conditions are.
These the animals,
they take them into captivity and then they just totally sees up.
They don't want to eat,
so they have to force feed.
You want to kill themselves.
They're depressed beyond belief.
Well,
they don't live with their pack anymore and they probably either in a swimming
pool.
She said,
get out either.
There's no way to get out.
Can you imagine if something took humans and couldn't understand our words and
trapped us in some fucking alien fish tank and just stared at us.
Oh my God.
Forced Veggie.
We would be horrified if we found out that one of our people was taking
captivity like that.
Hold on a second.
We wouldn't think,
oh,
he lived to be the same age as a regular person.
And that's what they're saying.
It's vile.
But I've always called them.
Not though they really are.
I Dunno know.
Remember the one a few years ago that he had killed three or four trainers,
Columbia is that his name?
To kill him.
And people were like,
oh my God.
And you're like,
um,
that question isn't really like,
why did he kill them?
She,
his job as a killer whale I think you'll find is too,
yeah.
Kill things and eat them.
I mean,
it was obviously out of frustration,
not out of,
uh,
I mean I'm not,
you know,
I'm just saying when they,
when they execute animals for killing keepers,
it always seems,
you know,
sort of like putting the question before the answer.
If you were in captivity,
you would certainly try to kill anything that was fucking with you.
And no,
either you're talking about something that doesn't have any moral standards.
There's no,
I mean,
we only assume that they have moral standards of behavior that they follow
because they all follow,
but they,
they commit genocide on a regular basis.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not saying that they're perfect because they're not perfect.
Dolphins commit infanticide,
dolphins,
rape,
and then orchids eat dolphins.
They know they're smart.
They killed dolphins all the time.
So we're not dealing with,
it's not a black and white issue here.
It's not like they're the angels of the sea.
They're ruthless murderers.
Yeah.
All of them.
But they're awesome,
you know?
And that's their world.
I was going to say,
but they're there.
That's what they're born to do.
That's what we are too.
We're just pretending we're not because we're here and you know,
fucking the valley in the fucking office park.
I mean,
it's ridiculous,
man.
It was a real ridiculous,
we're pretending you're not a part of this machine is crazy fucking machine.
It's just the numbers are different and it distributed in a,
in a more unique way than in the dolphin world.
But ultimately the same shit gets done.
Your enemies get killed.
You know,
a lot of horrible shit goes down and then the orcas come in and fuck everybody
up.
It's not much different than being in Afghanistan when helicopters are flying
overhead.
Really similar.
It's quite similar.
I they,
I think they dress better.
I love the Orca Motif.
You know,
the black and white is always there.
It documentaries causing real problems for seaworld.
That's great.
People,
the people in seaworld too.
I know that this is how they make their living and I know that they enjoy making
a living this way,
but you can't do it.
You can't do it.
I like what Michelle Michelle Rodriguez says,
she said that they should invest money in making robots,
you know,
for like the make make,
make fish,
robots and state of those things would kill people.
That's a good idea.
But I think the really the smart idea is to set up an area where there's no
fucking pollution where you develop a relationship with pods of dolphins.
So you communicate with them and exchange food for their attention and you come
and hang out with them and they're fucking smart.
They'll figure it out.
They don't have to go chase in tune off.
They'd go near this one particular raft would they have developed a treaty with
human beings.
So the human being show up with tuna,
which would be far fucking cheaper than a giant building filled with shit.
But we could all get our shit together and just make friends with these fucking
things and give them food exchange for love.
We would have a good time with dolphins,
but instead we have dolphin prison camps and we,
you know,
paid to see them and they do flips in the commercials and in sync and
everybody's happy.
Yeah.
It's pretty freaky.
It's freaky.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
we always think we're more superior to,
they always talk about ancient Rome and you know,
the cause ancient Rome was so cruel and uh,
gladiators and then all the animal shows,
they used to kill thousands of animals.
But this is kind of our Roman mom really is taking highly developed creatures
who can do complex behavior and you're training them to do these things for our
amusement and using it at a base,
sort of selling popcorn level.
And that's how
I feel bad because I have that photo of me and it's often now,
like I said,
remove or change Monterey from marine land on my luggage and it's the best thing
in the world because I can always tell it's mine.
I should have told anyone that now next luggage rock
will smell them.
I will smell.
I've got to grab his luggage because he's got a Max.
Um,
yeah.
You didn't think about it at the time.
It was before we had that dude on right before blackfish.
Yeah,
before black fishing before.
But I've always had this thing about dolphins.
I got really high once in a boat in Hawaii and it changed my life just because
you want it off.
The dolphins were jumping around and that was yelling to them and they were
doing flips and we were looking at each other in the eyes and I was so
barbecued.
Yeah.
It was just so barbecued that I,
I felt this really crazy connection with this animal and I got to thinking while
while this was going on,
I was like,
this is just like me.
It's just me living a different life.
And then I'm like,
I bet if I was in that dolphins head,
I would probably be thinking the way he thinks I would be living in that dolphin
world.
And if he was me,
he would probably,
you know,
if he had a language and he could use my lips and all that,
I mean,
if he understood English,
he'd probably be just like me.
And I'm like,
this is the same thing as us.
It's just in a different world.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It really is just like us.
And people deny that because they don't have stuff that's,
that's the only thing that they're only reason why they don't.
I mean,
what the fuck animal,
that's a wild animal.
It does this in place with a kitty cat.
Come on,
man.
You can't keep that in captivity.
That thing is smart as fuck.
It has a cerebral cortex,
40% larger than a human beings.
Those things are really smart.
They just don't have to have thumbs in their world.
Thumbs would get in the way.
They don't have to build houses.
They just go swim with a waters.
Awesome.
They just eat fish and fucking party and so they,
their fingers actually turned into flippers over time and they didn't need
fingers.
These things started out on the ground.
They were smart as shit.
Way Smarter than a cat or a dog.
Way Smarter than a monkey.
I mean these things are fucking smart.
Really smart.
Like fucking people smart like flipper smart.
Maybe even smarter about that.
Maybe they sold flipper short because they were haters.
Yeah,
no shit.
Just like Lassie,
you know the ancient Greeks thought they were people were dying isis to turn
them into.
Yes.
Yeah.
It wasn't that the rumor.
Well
because they've always gotten along and the,
when the world was more sailor oriented,
like in the ancient times when you kept to the coast and you only went out for a
day or two because you couldn't even bring enough water with you and that sort
of,
the little Mediterranean dolphins were there always and dolphins were thought of
is friendly because they often pointed you the way,
right?
Sometimes they'd come around boats just to hang around people and the sales play
with them and killed them and eating them.
No,
they must've,
no,
I don't think they,
that they ate them in
as much in the Greek times.
I think they understood that they were more sensitive than that.
I'm sure they ate them occasionally.
When you go really hungry and you're out and you're going to eat one.
Yeah,
Japanese still do.
Do they eat them or they just murdered them?
Did they eat them?
I think that's why they do and they still serve them?
Yeah.
About there.
Well,
I think the cove,
the reason why they're killing them is they're saying that they,
they interfere with their tuna fishing.
They the wipe out too much of the tuna and so it's like killing the enemy.
It's like they feel like they have a finite amount of oil.
That's a great answer.
It's not a good one.
Oh yeah.
But there's no fish left anyway.
Is there really?
Well that was the other thing about Jiro dreams of Sushi.
He was talking about the difference and the quantity of fish that they used to
get out of the ocean.
Wasn't there a part in the coke that they actually showed that there was fish?
There was,
uh,
like they would test the fish what it was and they're like,
oh,
this is dolphin.
I feel like there was a part of them.
I don't know.
I couldn't watch the whole thing.
I had to shut it off.
They'll certainly,
they were right.
Roped into the tunic catches forever and ever if they,
if they are not still.
Yeah,
those things freak me out.
I've watched a video once.
The reason why I can't watch the movies,
cause I watched a video of a,
a Japanese fishermen killing dolphins with s w like a knife on a dock.
There were flopping around on the dock and he's slicing their neck and he's
jumping out of the way and he's aware that there's a camera on him.
So he's got this weird uneasiness about it.
It's really dark.
It's so disturbing to see that animal that's smart as a human and he's murdering
a human.
It's just like a human,
I mean,
the dolphins when at zero did appear like they were having fun and just
everything was
planning with people.
It's probably the highlight of their day.
Right.
You know,
if you went to prison and the prisoners couldn't kill you and they didn't have
arms and they just needed hugs,
they'd be,
they'd be hugging the shit out of you,
you know,
and that's what's going on with the dolphins.
That's not what's going on with killer whales,
which is why you can't get in the tank with killer whales because yeah,
they have the ability to kill you.
I mean,
the Dolphin probably could fuck you up really bad if it wanted to,
but there's been like no evidence of a dolphin ever doing that to a person.
They apparently don't fight us,
but killer whales have killed a bunch of people,
especially that only in captivity,
by the way.
We're looking at attacking the wild.
Nope.
No.
They've saved people in the wild.
They've saved strangers in the wild.
They're just fallen into the water.
They've helped people that were drowning.
They've nosed him up and brought him to other boats,
like literally moved on with their nose to the boat and let,
like they knew where their friends were and helped them.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's so sentient that they let animals go.
The,
when they hunt,
they will teach,
uh,
the like little kill a bunch of seals and they'll play with one and they all
have their,
their children learn how to hunt with this like one wounded seal.
And then they'll let it go.
They're like,
go,
you can go.
You know,
we,
we have a good exchange here.
We're not going to kill you,
but we needed to use you.
We feel bad.
We don't need to eat.
You were full
when they hunt blue whales and the bigger whales,
they,
they post up,
they do chew on one side and one on the other side of the estuaries and stuff.
And that's what,
when there's the migrate it,
uh,
when the blue migrate off California
Day,
the people who watch these things,
uh,
can't do anything about it and they didn't want to interfere but to kill her
whilst each shot to kill them.
And,
and they,
they hunt like Jurassic Park style,
you know,
it is drastic.
Went down the pipe and chew in the back so that you're lured out.
And then when you get in the middle,
the other one comes out at you and not see any of that.
Have you ever seen the videos?
Oh yeah.
I've seen them flipping the seals in the air and dolphins in the hair.
No.
The videos of them eat in a whale.
Oh golly.
Yeah.
It's dark.
There's some shocking,
I mean this is the new way of nature,
right?
This is the word.
Like you said,
they're murderers.
That's what they do.
It is the way of nature and it's our way to,
and you know,
we're hypocrites if we try to pretend that there's something wrong with the way
they live,
but it's just disturbing in its raw real God.
Jesus.
Zero concern for us watching.
Did you think that's sort of why?
I mean,
not to get out,
but I'm not,
I've never read Moby Dick,
but of course I'm familiar with the story,
but the whole idea of whaling,
which really still going a little bit in a couple of countries like Norway and
what not,
but um,
this country was founded on wailing,
you know,
the east coast,
uh,
especially New England.
Um,
they went all around the world and wailed the living daylights out of the
planet.
We're talking about hundreds of thousands of millions of whales they killed over
the course of 150,
200 years.
And uh,
that culture is so amazing.
The,
um,
the,
the danger,
the raw fucking danger of hunting whale in a boat.
You know,
you lowered three or four boats,
there's 20,
30 guys in each boat.
You're trying to put a jar in this fucker and then rope it on and then ride the
fucker until you waste it and then render it right on the side of the boat,
right.
Crane it up and you know,
Jesus Christ and then take all the oil out of that,
fill the whole bolt for the oil and you're out for weddings.
And he would go out for what,
a year and a half year.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then come try to come back to New England with all your staff.
And uh,
it sucks.
The whales are awesome because of whales were shithead.
Whaling would be awesome.
Like whales where were like monsters will make their life they depicted in that
way,
but they even need it
really sensitive.
And there's a real story of Moby Dick One whaler and a guy just grabbed,
you can go on like Smithsonian online.
There's a story about well ram in the boat.
Then they fucking fought those boats.
Tooth and nail.
The whales were smart and sometimes they just turn on the boats and Bam,
you know,
smashed with a sign and Bravo.
That was the seal.
Pull up the one where the killer whales eat a whale.
Cause uh,
that's,
that's the most disturbing one.
The playing with the seals.
Fascinating.
Um,
it just shows how intelligent they are.
They're actually training their young how to do this.
The train them had a tip I ice,
uh,
RAF's over to knock the seal down.
Wow.
You can eat them and they're practicing and showing the kid had to do it and
they're setting it up and putting the seal back in place.
I mean,
it's nuts when you watch it.
The level of intelligence,
they're fricking really smart,
really smart animals.
There's an every at 20,000 leagues under the sea.
Vite Joel,
Vern,
God,
I think I read it in high school,
you've seen in nearly the,
in the book there's scene where there's a bunch of killer
whales and they watched them go into a frenzy.
And also in the book,
uh,
they use the buried treasure that they pull off the bottom of the seat of
support or rebellion.
And clearly captain nemos not white.
He's like Indian or Indonesian.
Yeah,
yeah.
They go to this one island where this prince is being mean to the population and
that's where it kept an email,
gives all the gold too that he pulls off the bottom of the ocean.
And I always thought that's kind of an overlooked,
a little part of the book that basically Nimo goes like,
you're on my ship,
you have to do what I want.
And then when they go to this one place,
he's like,
oh,
he gave all the gold of the rubbles and that's just sort of gets glossed over.
Like he's not supporting the dominant paradigm while he's down there.
He's against the US government.
He's,
he's giving money to rebels in Indonesia.
It's,
it's a pretty,
it's pretty groovy politics in it.
And what,
what year was that?
That's like the 1880s and then,
um,
uh,
that's h g wells and Jules Verne,
Julia Frenchmen.
And they'll sit.
He Do,
who did it from the earth to the moon,
that one way that go to the moon.
First men in the moon.
Uh,
any road.
I'm fent fantastic island,
magical island.
What's the name of the one with the fucking,
you know,
they got to the island and all the giant cars or island treasure on last.
Robert Louis Stevenson forbidden that you give us an island.
You know,
it's another,
it's like a Scifi jewel.
Vern gets done over and over because it's the same five stories over,
you know,
ana,
she loves are always going to the moon of vi,
read war of the worlds.
The opening line is something like,
I can't remember the opening round,
I'm paraphrasing.
The Earth was,
we knew we were being watched or what we didn't know was we were being watched
and that's a great opening line for a Scifi novel.
The martians are watching us and then they shoved their ships and everything.
It's a beautiful Scifi novel because it's so precise.
There's no sigh.
He made up all the site and wells really did make it up.
Like he knew nothing about technology so it's awesome.
Just go,
what was a beam?
You know like so he,
you know how the tripods come out of the ships and they have laser beams and
they basically laser beam everything.
Like he just started made up but it's going to be this beam of pure energy or
whatever.
Like you know what's fascinating and he did do that,
but that's what a lot of people use as their template for the future.
When they thought about like future weapons,
it was always a laser beam.
It was always a beam.
Well,
I think once,
once physics were understood that things were in particles,
that wasn't that big a jump,
that there would be just be,
first of all,
this isn't Zeus is thunderbolts the ultimate,
you know,
dude,
I'm,
yeah.
Just,
I mean,
just thunder in general.
The idea of this power,
this electricity.
Everybody knew what electricity wasn't what it could do.
I would have loved to been alive before electricity was explained and see what
the fuck people were saying.
Did you imagine what people were saying back when,
you know,
people barely had a language,
they barely could string together a sentence and you would understand and the
fucking sky bolts of lane coming out.
It's kind of hitting the ground balls of light and fruit through a field.
You have to deal with that.
You know,
there's been an instance that I read about,
um,
we'll have ball lightning.
Like there's been instances of ball
lightning that they think explains you.
Ufos.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be surprised.
I think that did a lot of,
not all UFO was obviously yeah.
But some Ufo sightings,
they talk about these orbs that are flying orbs of light apparently under
certain geological pressures,
like certain pressures on near fault lines and,
and the like,
there's,
there's fucking bolts of lightening that would come out of the ground.
I wouldn't be surprised.
It's,
yeah,
it's supposed to in Atlanta it can last for like three or four seconds.
We'll have everything in the world is an electric charge and everything is
totally makes sense.
Right.
Just a weird spark,
you know,
that occurs.
What is this?
I've never seen ball light ball lightning.
Yeah.
It's really exciting.
My wife and I were in a Capri once and uh,
it,
it's a little island off the coast of Naples and um,
is that,
well I think they're saying this is ball lightning.
Yeah.
That could believe it with the ball.
Lightning cause ball lightning has weird properties.
Yeah.
Look,
look at that.
Just disappeared.
It,
it's a film roll in it righter than fuck.
So you can see it from miles away.
Right and right.
And you mourn when lightening hits things.
You know how you always see sparks?
Yeah.
Shit.
Well,
my wife and I were sitting,
we were having dinner and this and it's a little island and a big storm started
brewing on the Mediterranean and all of a sudden everything,
you know,
the ozone in the air and your hair starts to stand up.
And it was a light breeze and Capri smells like Lemons and bay leaves.
So it was really beautiful.
And I said to my wife,
and this is what a rabbit smells like right before the lid comes down on the
pond.
Bayleaf and lemon.
And then,
Hey,
I'm I,
oh,
uh,
and then we sat on the balcony of our hotel and the storm never hit Capri,
but it was several miles away and we watched it and it just,
just giant lightening strikes out and the clouds and then it never got close
enough to rain.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
that's great.
And it was,
yeah,
I said,
this is like watching the gods play,
right?
Like here we're sitting here with a glass of wine and the air was electric.
And all you,
you'd hear it,
you know,
and then you,
you see it and then you'd hear it afterwards because it was that far away that
now you need clouds to have lightening.
And the clouds were just crashing together and it would,
you'd see like,
Shit,
what I'm saying is where you were,
you didn't have to worry.
There's no clouds above you.
You didn't have to worry.
W we were,
it was at least a couple of miles away.
Wow.
So you don't have a clear sky said it.
Yeah.
Clear Mediterranean sky is simply that you could feel the raised electricity in
the air because there was a breeze blowing end and your hair was on an and.
Wow.
And there was a lot of ozone,
you know,
from all the crashing,
but it never got close enough to,
it never hit the island.
It never poured rain.
It just sort of stayed right off the island.
And I was like,
that's so exciting.
If I could always have storms to spectate,
you know,
cause she'd watch a ball just like shoot from one cloud to another arking rope,
you know?
And,
and it was endlessly entertaining.
There's nothing more entertaining than lightening,
you know,
then that the noise of the thunder in that smell of,
especially if you know you're not going to die.
That was what made it so great.
We were sitting there with a joint in a glass of wine.
It was like,
you know,
heavenly cause if you're in a city,
like if you're in New York City,
no storm goes on.
You have this weird feeling that lightening could hit this fucking building
anytime and my windows could explode.
I was on a plane with my wife going into Frankfurt,
Germany for the World Cup like in 2006 and we flew through a giant electrical
storm.
So we're on the plane and I'm looking out the window and the plane's bouncing up
and down and the giant ball of lightening struck the wing of the plane.
Oh my watch on.
And it went like this and then bang.
And that was a huge booming noise.
The lights dimmed for a second and went right back on.
And everyone on the planet like that,
right?
Oh my gosh.
Flight attendants went fucking white.
Which then,
then I was a little scared because I thought,
well they shouldn't be freaked out.
Right.
And my wife like,
you know,
panicky and I went,
not that I was so great,
but I went the wing still there.
Let's start there,
then hit the wing.
The wing is completely intact.
It hit the lightening rod at the end of the,
you know,
the little metal thing they have at the end of the week.
They have a metal thing trines play telling us,
uh,
an exoskeleton thing around them.
So lightening hits,
it's disperses around the planet to prepare for that.
Obviously you have to write because they're going to fly through electricity
that look at that picture.
Oh my God.
Planes.
You never hear about planes blowing up because it got hit by looking at this,
watch this.
Oh,
that.
It's crazy because when you see it in real life,
it looked like nothing.
Like so fast.
Yeah.
Let me see what it actually is.
It got hit and then the pilot didn't come off for like 10 minutes.
That rat,
he let us all sweat and everybody was like scared shitless.
Maybe.
Then the pilot came on and he talked like Kissinger.
He was German obviously,
but he,
he first,
he didn't German than in English,
but when he spoke in English she sounded like Kissinger,
homos,
and everybody was like,
oh my God,
what's going on here?
But it looks scary.
This is the Turkish airplane hit by lightening strike inside playing video.
But I don't know why there was sparks going at the door.
The doors.
Oh,
they just got hit right there and the lights go out.
Oh my God,
this is terrifying.
The mountains.
Shit's terrifying man.
Shut it off now.
We're going to be nice.
Don't ever put that back on again.
We got to fly everywhere.
I'm flying this weekend is the light together and drive.
Come on man,
man.
Flying through the sky with the fucking gods are angry,
I think.
Did I tell you this one?
If I've told it,
I'll stop and we'd flied out [inaudible] and was on a little plane.
Usually you're on a giant plane,
but it was on like a seven 37 you know like
a Virgin Australia,
which has a groovy airline.
So on the flight with me and my wife has a,
the game,
you know this guy is a rapper,
right?
He's got a tattoo on his head,
whatnot.
And Kerry hill then who's also a rapper and a and their posse,
right?
So it's hectic,
It starts to get them MP and the pilot comes on and goes like everybody strapped
in.
Okay.
For like ever.
And Australia is 15 hours,
16 minutes long.
It's just the whole day.
And this lasted literally five hours,
right?
Wow.
Just bouncing up and down,
side to side,
pitching yard,
the whole thing.
And on the,
on the sky map,
right?
It says like Paygo,
Paygo,
1500 kilometers,
meaning your 1500 kilometers from paygo,
paygo.
In other words,
the Pacific Ocean is so big,
there's no land masses,
nothing anywhere near you where you're going over.
Right?
So you're not going to go in because its turbulence,
it's not your fucking freaking me out.
You're not going to die.
This isn't electricity.
Turbulence doesn't make planes crash and it doesn't,
unless there's some sort of hideous structural defect and the plane like that,
you know,
the wings aren't glued on or whatever.
But I mean a structural defect generally,
generally now you've been in a play with turbulence.
They don't,
you know,
that's not what makes them crashing,
you know.
But anyways,
it's terrible in any case.
So we get through it and next morning,
uh,
the rappers get up and they're all like,
oh my God,
I thought I was going to die.
And you know,
it was so bad last night I,
you know,
I was praying and La,
la,
they're all like really shook up and carry.
Hilton is a very lovely young rapper.
Lady wakes up,
it's been all night.
Mind you,
no one can move.
I stopped holding my wife's hand for five,
you know,
like,
like this for you know,
cause like this,
oh what happened and the rappers,
cause you didn't feel that we are going to die that night.
Claims by another young woman.
She goes,
I took a pill,
I didn't see anything and beans and motherfucker.
It was an end.
Then she ate one piece of fruit and put on a leopard mini skirt and came at him
with her makeup and signed autographs and I was like,
you're a star.
I want you on my team.
You are Alexander the Great.
We,
everyone was scared.
The adrenaline you could smell in the plane,
you know what I mean?
From five hours of bouncing,
you know,
just that,
oh,
you know,
you want it to stop,
stop bouncing so we can start producing.
And she just woke up a word.
Yeah.
Fucking put on a pushup bra getting ready to for the photo call.
When they got off the plane,
I believe he did tell the story.
I remember this,
but I just loved you sat her several.
A Pharaoh was like,
you gotta be kidding me,
man.
Yeah.
It was either this podcast or another podcast or heard you tell a story.
It's really,
I remember,
I remember it now after it's over.
We talked about the girl getting out and changing.
Yeah.
That's a great story.
Wow.
It's great that someone could be that,
that out cold on ambient.
So there's positive things to ambien.
I was talking about,
she had about Ambien,
but if ambien can get you to avoid that,
not one minute of it.
And it lasted for,
I'm sorry I didn't to repeat it,
but it always made me laugh because I was scared to death and when I got off the
plane I look like,
you know,
something James Brolin sat on,
I was squishy and moist.
What's your dams per day?
Yeah.
And it,
you know,
you're,
you're just wracked,
eh.
Uh,
and all I wanted to do is like,
you know,
eat a club sandwich and die,
cause you're like,
God,
we're on the ground.
And she just like,
Hey,
who's for pictures?
That's hilarious.
Does something to being oblivious.
Oh,
oblivion.
Is it really?
No,
no brain,
no pain.
I had a friend that was a martial artist and uh,
he would get like real nervous and you know,
real upset before fights and he couldn't understand why some people wouldn't,
why the people work like calm and relaxed.
And I said,
you're smarter.
Yeah.
I said,
you know that about the consequences.
You're,
you're aware of the possibilities are you,
you have more of a burden,
you have a burden of understanding.
Whereas this is a bunch of people and here the thing through the baddest mother
fucker that ever lived,
you know,
you're not the baddest mother fucker that ever did lived,
but you get this strange thrill out of competing and you,
you,
you find yourself compelled to see how far you can push it,
but you're well aware of the consequences.
So you better be careful,
you know,
be careful.
You're fucking,
you're smart.
You're thinking.
That's why people freak out.
The people that don't freak out,
the people that can just skate through that like you don't want that you don't
want,
that's more of a burden or the lack of awareness that you get by staying in your
job,
I suppose.
Yes.
But I mean like not being terrified of things that everybody else is terrified.
Yeah.
Well you can die quicker from it for sure because those people are asking for
it.
That there is certain awesomeness in oblivion that keeps you,
yeah.
Can you power style?
Well there's the thing about acting to an athletics,
right?
Cause there's,
you know,
like I love a panda on the San Francisco giants that there our third baseman.
Anyone else would tell you to come up to the bat and think about what the
pitcher's throwing and your chances of hitting it in a certain zone and you want
to put a good swing on it and he seems to just lunge it shit.
It's over his head or down to his ankles and there's no rhyme or reason,
but he's a superb hitter.
He's got to strengthen the coordination to do it at this point.
And so they manage a cat,
say anything when he calls one right into the stands,
off his ankles on a pitch.
You should surely be laying off of that.
Any coach would be up your Dick for fucking offering on,
you know what I mean?
There's a certain amount of oblivion to that that I just think,
well that's the kind of player you are.
You know,
there's that babe Ruth quality of like,
fuck you.
I drank 20 beers,
I fucked three girls.
I eight five hot dogs and I hit a home or what the fuck's your problem?
Well,
it's also,
I think
there's not the same consequences that there is with fighting.
You know,
fighting using sucks.
Yeah.
But the people that have no concern whatsoever,
genuinely have no concerns,
they're dangerous or they're in trouble too.
They're there not just dangerous.
They're in trouble.
Cause you gotta be,
you have to be scared.
Literally your,
your reflex is,
won't be tuned in correctly if you're not
scared,
you really shouldn't compete unless you have some nerves.
You really should feel it.
Otherwise it's dangerous.
Like guys get cracked sometimes when they're overconfident because they go into
a fight thinking that this isn't a threat.
When it's a huge threat and the other person's on full threat,
the other person's fully adrenaline Dava and they're moving it like,
you know,
40% faster than they ever would in real life.
And you're not,
you know?
Right.
And then you're going to get kicked in the head.
Yes.
You're not going to see it coming.
You're not alert.
You're not scared.
So you're not level,
you're not moving quickly or you're not like really amped up.
You're not totally,
it's very important and it's really difficult for stupid people.
Stupid people have,
if nothing's happened to them yet,
they think they're fine.
They're in vulnerable.
What about him performing?
I find like a,
a friend of mine said to me years ago,
you get a script and this is just a lane premise,
but you get the idea like it's an audition and it's not a very funny scene,
right?
You're smart enough to look at it.
One,
because you have a sense of humor and chill.
Your intelligent to look at and go the scenes sucky.
I gotta do something with it,
whereas a stupid or actor looks at it and goes,
man,
that's hilarious.
Right?
The barrier of like the editorial commenting,
you know,
also people get really delusion with anything that they're involved in or
anything that they want to get.
They start thinking it's much better than it really is.
I've had friends tell me,
oh my God,
dude,
there's this pilot we're filming.
You got to read the script.
It's fucking hilarious.
And then you read it,
you're like,
oh my God,
this is shite.
It's lessons shite on a stick.
Yeah,
you shouldn't do this.
You turn this down.
I turned them down.
Now when something comes up that's really,
really,
I don't even read for it.
I just like,
I can't,
I don't get offered anything.
But it would,
if I did,
I'd have morals and that attorney,
the only,
the only acting I've done it all in the last few years has been with Kevin
James,
Kevin jammies.
Just cause he's such a nice guy.
He's such a sweetie.
I love being around them.
And you know,
he's a pal from our early days of a comedy in her twenties but other than that,
like auditioning for things and preparing food basics,
I missed that boat.
It's too much work.
It's a lot of work.
Too much.
So when we can create our own little wizard realm,
I don't know why.
I don't want,
the stress of it is so horrible.
You wouldn't have as much fun in a movie as you would do in a podcast.
And I never have as much wind doing anything.
It's idea that having podcasts,
no,
I'm serious.
Bad.
You're killing in front of all these people live creating things on the left
more than anything you've ever,
I mean I stand up in podcasting,
both my favorite things ever,
but anymore just to being able to even control it to this level that we are now.
When we look at,
look at what,
15 years ago?
Yeah.
We couldn't have done it.
No we could,
we wouldn't have never got hired by radio stations.
Neither one of us.
And now we're,
we're our own crappy radio station.
That's great.
Yeah.
I mean I had always thought about doing radio.
I always thought it would be really fun,
but there was always that they tell you what to say.
Oh you got to do with a program or cause like every time we did a morning show
there was always,
well it's fucking new executives and asshole.
He won't let us talk about tampons on the air.
Like you can't say this,
you can't say the r word.
Remember the Joe Show a little Austin,
was that?
Yeah.
Dale Dale and Bob Dale.
Dudley.
That was right when you weren't allowed to say retarded anymore.
Well,
they had a bunch of rules that they were having.
I think when we would go on,
the first couple of times I went on and was sorta hog wild and then as time went
on they pulled back on that.
Well,
radio is changing.
It's not,
there's not a lot of like,
there's used to be just in Boston alone,
there was a series of morning Djs for rock stations.
There was Charles Laquidara,
there was the guys on Aaf who the Hillman now.
There was,
there was all these different revive station,
classic rock station.
Everybody knew them.
Everybody knew the Djs is mark Parenteau,
who's the afternoon guy in Boston.
Everybody knew.
These guys tell big dice to pieces,
man,
they're competing with us.
Dot.
To be honest,
because they have to do podcasts.
If they're ready or she has to and stuff or they're going for older demo.
I find myself on a Lotta easy listening or more classic he pop type things that
have the bigger,
broader reach.
Where now,
where it used to be that guy show now three or four other guys who had their own
shows are all on that show too and
glom together.
Well a lot of radio stations offer like a supplemental podcast.
Now I know Kevin and being do that opie and Anthony do that.
They have a podcast too.
If you titans like Bob and Tom have an empire in the Midwest.
Yeah.
You all,
yeah,
no those guys could still do it.
Kevin and being could still do it but it's less than less man.
It used to be like there was thousands of them,
you know,
three or four in San Francisco just alone just in San Francisco and that's a
small market.
Right.
And then now there's one,
two and it cut back on what the east to let you be on an hour and now we
changed.
We want people to listen to more,
you know,
crappy music or whatever that they think if you not delivering joke,
joke,
joke.
People are not going to tune in.
They want to give you like a real quick like five minute interview.
And then you're on your way and you're like,
I got up at five in the morning for this,
let me stop for half an hour and I'll light it up.
Light it.
Yeah,
let's have some fun.
And they used to be that you could go on and be,
you can,
you can do a lot of local radio.
We do two,
three hours and sit with them.
Just have fun.
And you would be in with them for the morning and they'd be like,
can you stick around?
You'd be like,
yeah.
And he's there till 10 o'clock and everybody's laughing.
You'd shake hands is a lot of fun.
Y'All had a good time together.
But those places are few and far between these days.
They're really thin on the ground now.
Yeah,
it's probably,
they've lost half their ranks and that's my gas is they lost and they had to
consolidate and they're owned by smaller and smaller.
Yeah.
Owner base and the old when we're starting,
and we're talking a while ago,
there was hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of radio stations owned by
different people and now how many people open,
how many corporations own most of them yet for three?
Well,
when we're talking about audible.com earlier in the portable personal MP three
player,
once that sort of integrated and it started becoming an option that you could
play whatever you want it to on your phone and then you could just listen to it
on car.
God Damn,
everything changed.
The whole thing just dropped off.
I bet people started burning cds and they got online of all the music they
wanted to listen to and then they're like,
well how do we replace this fucking talking thing?
And then boom,
podcast show up.
Yeah.
It's,
we live in very Trans Trans Dental,
transcendental transitionary,
transgender,
very transgender.
My friends on both sides,
both sides of the fence.
Pro All sides.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
w we live in the weirdest time ever as far as like things changing.
Thank God.
I think it,
it changed.
It made me love everything again.
We were talking about Google glass really,
and it's gotten me to thinking there was a video online of a guy was attacked by
a shark and he lost his arm and his leg and they made them these wicked carbon
fiber.
A bionic parts.
It was like walking around.
Yeah.
Pull that guy up.
Australian man bitten by shark has a cyborg arm and a leg.
I mean,
I think I've met this guy.
He was a policeman.
Really?
And he was on the bomb squad,
was it?
No,
I mean,
I'm sure if I met a guy four years ago,
three years ago,
and he had a prosthetic hand that it and it,
you know,
like it was a black,
the black thingy.
I met a guy who has a prosthetic hand as well.
The same kind of hand at the global future,
20,
45 initiative in New York.
Wow.
Is this a future trends?
You know,
all it was all this um,
uh,
the transcendental man movie stuff.
That's cute.
Cute.
You know,
all their Kurtzweil stuff,
all this stuff about extending life.
And this guy had lost his hand and they had given him this bionic recreation of
a hand and it was carbon fiber and he would shake your hand with it and it was
pliable and he could,
he could,
you know,
apply varying levels of resistance.
And it's really interesting to say,
but what I thought about,
I was like,
well,
absolutely,
it'd be better to have that than to have you know.
No hand,
right?
Yeah.
Here's a guy right here.
This is the guy that was not him.
It will be the best way to defend ourselves against,
he lost his one arm and one leg to a shark movie.
It was on the side by see if he could pull ahead and he shows it.
He shows his,
uh,
arm and his leg and you get a chance to see,
I mean,
the guy's walking around and standing there like,
you know,
he's part robot man.
And what I was thinking is it's absolutely better to have that than not have
your hand,
we,
but we all agree,
right?
We would definitely want that.
But a prosthesis leg,
see his leg.
It's so cool.
He's got balance.
You can walk.
It's awesome.
It's totally awesome.
Now here's the question.
What if they could do that to your whole body?
How does your body,
exactly.
We're going to start doing parts though.
I think they're going to start with like eyes.
Like you're going to have night vision,
Zoom Lens in your idea.
You're going to have an article.
Here's something to consider for you.
I really haven't type fans of Scifi.
Uh,
what about when the rich get onto the poor and start farming them for parts and
then basically have your head put on a poor person's body.
She can afford it,
man.
Yeah,
because you paid that family this much and they fucking
dealer one of the uncles.
If you don't think they're already jumped to that with Oregon's and every other
goddamn thinking in the world.
Well,
sure.
I mean that,
wasn't that movie hostile about that or was it about torture
or just torturing people?
I think,
but I think,
um,
you know,
there's been a million of those urban legends of someone hanging out with a
Russian check and waking up in a bathtub filled with ice with stitches and a
note on you.
This is go to the doctor immediately.
Yeah,
he kept on telling me that in Japan you're like,
stay away from those Russians.
Brian,
they'll harvest jargons,
man who you don't want to get involved with the mercenary Russian hooker who has
also has a scalpel in her purse.
That's really good advice.
And a wet rag she's trying to show in your mouth.
Cause one thing I've learned from Joe today,
smell my perfume is intoxicating.
No,
the room,
he seems to be getting smaller.
Does it not?
Well I do look so dizzy blind and this sweet Boosie Boosie anymore.
You'll get things sleepy before you like me.
Like me.
Once you smell my perfume.
Oh two bed to bed.
I take your liver,
I think your kidney.
Yeah,
they,
she pricks you on the finger earlier in the day to get your blood type.
Then they set up the coolers,
coolers full of ice,
and fucking put a wet rag over your face and open you up like a,
like a dolphin on a deck in Japan,
slice and then got your liver or whatnot.
And rich guy lives forever.
Yeah.
People will kill people for money.
We all know that.
Right?
Well,
people will definitely steal people's organs for money.
Oh yeah,
they will.
Oh,
we gotta be careful that my shows,
there's a lot of people looking for kidneys and whatnot.
A lot of pancreas,
pancreas Steve's.
I got a guy tried to steal my iro Langer hands.
Thank God I wasn't sitting.
What is that?
I don't know.
It's just some Oregon that's happening here.
All up in your thingy.
That's an actual organ.
Yeah,
that just loved the name of that process.
You have a Google there.
Try selling the use of Langur hands.
I think it's a little gland up in your urethra area,
your reader area.
If they could give you cadaver dicks,
if dudes could get to cadaver Dick's.
Like if you were born with a week Dick,
and you always want a big Dick,
but there's just the only way he could get one cadaver Dick's and it turns out
they don't use cadavers.
Dicks they use like,
you know,
ligaments for knee replacements.
Like I had one of those done with a dabber part.
They use Oregon's,
you can be an organ donor but you can't be a dick donor.
How can we can't be a dick donor if they could do that shit with hands.
What if a dude has like a really tiny deck and he's willing to take a chance?
They really get it down pat,
do you think that one day like motorcycle victims will donate their dicks?
I'll give you a motorcycle rider.
You're crazy dude.
But you've got a giant deck and you know it's valuable so you get a break on
your taxes.
I just,
I donated mine.
I have the gender card for Costa Rica.
The whole country gets to share mine cause it's pretty big the whole country.
A lot of people in Costa Rica,
Bro.
Stop bragging.
Well,
it's a small country.
I'm known as El Guapo there.
It's not like you said China.
Yeah,
they get the whole,
all the Chinese could share.
My Dick did it.
Did we define what the olive lagger hand did?
I don't think,
I don't know if it has a specific purpose,
but it's a,
I have to Pete,
thank you for that sharing and that I just wanted to let you know I'm,
I'm,
I do too,
but I'll go after you.
You didn't.
The pancreas that contain a whatever.
Wow.
That's pretty vague.
Well,
it doesn't really say what it does.
It just says it's in there.
It's,
yeah.
I don't know that it has a specific function,
but I love the name.
Why is it an aisle and who's Mr Langer hand?
Yeah,
it's weird.
Oh,
look at this picture.
Oh no,
that's alright.
That there it is.
Where is it?
I don't know.
I just,
it looks like a Dick.
I don't know why that has anything to do with it.
It doesn't say anything on there.
Whatever.
Diabetes.
Okay,
great.
Do you have any tour dates you want to
flood?
I guess at this point in the show I should really,
I have a video coming out on,
uh,
March 26 you can go to my website,
Greg proops.com and you can preorder it now.
It's live at Musso and frank,
I came on to plug it last year.
You may recall Brian,
but um,
that company folded the week that we were supposed to drop the video.
Right?
What,
what was that again?
Well,
that was chill,
nevermind them.
Uh,
and it was through no fault of theirs in a way.
But in any case,
uh,
now it's going to come out again.
Yeah,
there you are.
There's my website.
See that thing,
that banner there?
You can click on that and you can order it.
The member of the video is add May.
Last year she'll run out of business.
The week it was supposed to drop.
And so now it's coming out again on March 26th,
but you can preorder it now.
So what happened?
Showing out of business,
they bit coined it.
Yeah.
So for 99 years and if you,
uh,
if you use the code proofs,
you get for I think $4,
so it's really,
wow,
it's four bucks.
It's an hour long video.
I made it.
It's coming out much 26.
It's a lie that Musso and Frank's,
thank goodness it wasn't topical material.
It was evergreen material that I think both boys and girls and men and women
alike can relate to.
Um,
I'm joking.
Of course boys and girls and boys and girls,
no one's going to be uncomfortable.
No,
I think everyone will be uncomfortable and that's my goal.
That's as good as Tom Lehrer once said,
if I could make a loved one,
slap another level and then it's all been worthwhile for me as a comedian.
Um,
dom Irrera and I talked about you putting your show on at Musso and Frank's,
we both agreed it's such a brilliant idea.
It's like the perfect place because it's got this beautiful old Hollywood
feeling to it.
Like it's a great place to eat.
It's like sort of like I'm the one place on Santa Monica Boulevard,
the steakhouse
palms.
No.
The other one then Cantana I laughed at that place has got that same sort of
school,
Hollywood and great food.
Musso and Frank's end.
Yeah.
So when
I heard that you were doing it there,
I was like,
God,
grains Santana did a great place to put it on the sheet would be,
it was just really fun.
But anyway,
we're finally coming out with a,
it's just taken,
so you know,
it's one of those journeys.
Is it available now?
You can preorder it now.
If you click that thing on my site,
[inaudible] dot com I have add and then,
um,
it'll come out on the 26th and then you'll be able to watch it immediately.
And yes,
people watching in Australia and England and Ireland and all of the Joe Rogan
heirs,
uh,
of those bold Rogan errors all over the world.
Uh,
you may watch it as well.
It is simply downloadable to whatever device you've got.
And like I say,
if you read proofs in the little code there,
I love,
it's 20% off with $5.
Well,
20% off or $5 is a dollar.
I'll make it real bloody simple for everybody.
Sound as good.
20% sounds juicy or 20% is a lot.
It is a lot,
but with $5 it's really $4 so it's very reasonable.
And we should,
we both have to thank Louis Ck for coming up with this idea.
I totally,
yeah,
I know you do.
I do to everybody does.
It's a beautiful idea that he came up with,
I'm hoping it works and we put out our podcasts for free and you don't have to
pay for them.
And so people sometimes in on the end and you're like,
how can I help you or whatever.
And it's like well spend the $4 on this and that would be a nice way to,
yeah,
that's a nice thing to do.
I support like if I found out about a good music or find a song that I really
enjoy it,
I buy it at a principal.
I always need Joe.
And if I enjoy it,
especially if I,
you know,
someone sends me a youtube clip or something like that.
If you get good feelings from someone's art,
if you can support it,
you should support it.
And I totally understand that people are broke.
Oh,
me too.
Thanks free.
Don't spend money on me man.
Before you,
you know,
I should be at the end of your list,
but you know,
if you want to go buy a tank phone,
go and go get a Tang.
If you wanna join,
push you out.
Help out some of those sponsors.
Oh,
you said I'm playing tonight at the bar I live at and that's free.
Where's that at?
I live,
which is our now Santa Monica Boulevard,
uh,
right near,
um,
uh,
like the Formosa.
What would you say?
It's close.
It's across street from the pleasure chest.
You brands people.
You're a crafty bastard and it's free to come to that.
That's my podcast.
Seven o'clock till you crafty and how you move,
man.
I like,
how are you doing shows in these,
a unorthodox locations.
Oh,
everybody plays a part.
Lubitsch yet.
Josh and Josh has his show there.
And uh,
not everybody man.
Well,
some people that's,
it's,
it's unorthodox.
It's fairly an orthotic.
The laugh factory.
It's not the Improv.
No,
I can't,
you know,
it's,
it's got a little back room and there's a VOD compile out frank.
Uh,
so,
and there's a little patio up front so you can get your story of,
you know,
the,
I mean it has its full service.
How big is the room?
Oh,
Janky.
What would you say?
50,
60 shows there.
That's how you see a little red cushions.
And there's always lots of women.
It's a very women friendly atmosphere.
It's not that duty.
You know,
it's,
it's pretty chill.
And go there,
dude.
How do you,
uh,
who books that shit?
I'll get you on it.
I'll give you the right sounds.
Awesome.
I love,
I love that little room at the Ice House.
That's my current favorite room.
That little 80 seat room.
Yes.
You know,
I don't usually do the big room,
which is still awesome.
It's only 150 but that little room,
God damn,
that little room is magical for coming up with new material.
It's like the crowd like totally lets you know what's funny about it and what's
not.
There's not a lot.
There's a weird fluff that you get.
Like you get extra laughs when you get like 300 people.
Like did get people that like get into a rhythm and I start laughing at anything
and he seen you get confused.
It's whether or not a bit is good or not,
but 80 people will give you the fucking real deal though.
They'll kick you the real deal.
Um,
Marshall Child's room in Atlanta called the laughing skull.
Yes.
Love that place.
And that's
not working there.
It's not working.
But when it's working it's working.
Well,
you know,
even that is fat compared to what we used to do at the store.
The beautiful thing about the store is that if there was two fucking people in
that place,
you did a show for two people.
I did that.
A danger fields to danger fields in Minot and needs to be like that.
They would have two people would walk in and the MC would start the show like
the nine 30 there was no show going on.
The comics are waiting by the bar and at the store,
as long as there's people still sitting down,
it's two o'clock in the morning.
You might have to go up and perform for two fucking people.
And it's super common.
Like,
you know,
like once a week there'll be a show like that.
Oh well you,
you could possibly have a late spot and there's no one in the audience.
Right.
And Don Berry every night.
He had one person the other day and he spent like 20 minutes on that person that
made that prison that night I got the back roads,
all comics,
you know,
it's beautiful.
Dawn barristers.
What does comedy though?
Yes,
it is comedy.
And it's also,
again,
you,
you cut all the fat out when it's a tiny ass.
That's all I,
other than in mortality is Shakespeare said is all I seek.
All I seek is you want that connection.
And so I like a little rim and I like alcohol.
A small room.
Real closeup.
I don't,
uh,
I love Vic ran.
Then you know,
you throw javelins and you know,
you got to make big faces and you got a big g big gestures and you,
you're doing a different show.
It's a different show.
That's the small room you can incubate,
you can raise your eyebrow,
you can,
you can intimate.
You don't have to fucking lay down and suppressing fire to keep the aliens from
killing you.
I like both.
This is what I like.
I like for developing material.
I like a little tiny show.
I look a little tiny room for fucking around like a little tiny room,
but I just don't like doing places like the Chicago theater or like Massey Hall,
like those really big places.
There's something,
a lecture Yale about 3000 plus people that are laughing their asses off and
having a great time and it's like you're so on point.
You're so like tuned into them because there's so much density in the air.
But I think that is a different show.
It's a different show than you would do in a cloud.
It's a big louder.
Yeah,
it's much loud and you can't just leave dead air out there the same way because
it will just start yelling shit out.
There's
just too many people that are drinking and having fun.
And there's that diffusion of responsibility that takes place when you've got
massive groups like that,
like people feel less responsible for the fun.
Like if there's two people in the crowd,
no one's going to stand up and go
foggy.
No.
But if you're in the middle of some 3000 seat place,
some asshole might do that.
Yeah.
He might get lit up and want to be the center of it.
That's true.
Now when there's two people,
there's a lot more assumption of responsibility.
Yeah.
They can't look at energy for Beth.
But I think for the podcast,
for me,
I like it like the Bar Lubitsch energy because it is small.
And last time we did it,
there wasn't very many people.
That was maybe
20.
And I and I had a great time.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
you don't,
you don't need a giant crowd.
It's,
it's fun to,
uh,
also I don't,
when you're doing a podcast to you,
you're,
you're always thinking about people are listening individually.
People aren't sitting like in a Scifi movie from the 70s,
all in a giant room listening to a speaker.
Although it'd be great if people had to listen that way.
Like in the movie colossus,
the Fob in project where when the computer took over the world,
finally it adjust the world and it's like I am colossus.
And then there was a montage of like in China,
a bunch of people standing all in a huge group listening to a speaker,
you know,
and then in England and whatnot,
ice 11,
the Scifi movies when they would do that,
when they divide the world up for that big world domination message.
I was going to say,
when we're talking about lightening earlier,
that the other thing that I would love to have no knowledge of and experience,
it was the war of the worlds broadcast.
Oh Orson Welles did to be in that time,
this fearful,
strange time where you really did think that this person on the radio must be
telling the truth because that's how they got on the radio.
Yeah,
I mean there were so fucking childlike and this idea that this hg wells book,
a pretty famous book being read by a pretty famous guy and Orson Welles that
somehow or another this was real.
Well they,
they did at the beginning of course came on like it was regular mercury theater,
but then the style that they did the show in was documentary style salad.
They took the premise,
so it would be like a novel going,
Y'all reportive and Glover's mills and [inaudible] in the field and Grovers
Gloversville Josie,
what you hear behind me is maintained.
So there's no video.
You just hear people doing that and I and shit like that.
And then people being interviewed,
I'm like,
oh yeah,
they were coming down the road.
Like that's how they did the radio show.
So it totally worked as theater and the pointless,
everybody tuned in late.
I remember I said to my dad,
who was old enough to remember that show,
uh,
what about the people who lived in New Jersey?
I said,
cause he was in Brooklyn.
but the people who lived in New Jersey,
surely they knew that it wasn't happening around me when they were the most
scared of all because they could hear it on the radio happening down the street.
And people were literally,
that's where all the calls came from.
Was
that part of the east coast where,
and then people started to think they see saw of course things,
you know.
Well that's a huge issue with such a brilliant way to do the show.
That to pitch it over to news style in 1938 to two dad,
the wherewithal,
the not like you say,
they didn't go like the Martians were coming.
They made it immediate.
We're under attack and so brilliant motherfucker.
He was so ahead of his time as well.
You know,
his first of all,
I mean his,
his delivery the way he did that was brilliant.
The way he set that up was brilliant.
Um,
the,
the impact that it had,
but then when he did citizen Kane and now he does,
which didn't win best picture,
knocked it out of the park with this fucking movie and then started doing wine
commercials,
dropped off and got fal.
He's praised careers all over the yard.
He's kind of crazy,
right?
They gave him a lot of many and he tried to do heart of darkness by Conrad and
he went to South America and shot all this weird footage and [inaudible] never
really pulled it together on that project.
And I think at that point there,
that's when the funding sort of dried up halfway through.
You know,
you can't apocalypse now at some time.
Well he did it.
He,
he,
he's the original apocalypse now or I mean he really did go to South America and
tried to shoot this thing and like they were going to do,
you know,
the definitive version that was really subversive and really subliminal and you
know,
we'll make it this scary ass.
Cause if you know,
apocalypse is a version of heart of darkness,
but if you've ever read heart of darkness speaks to something that's immediate
to this world,
which is how we as colonials go in and take over other little nations and turn
them into,
you know,
the horror and all that.
Yeah.
You can forget how good that movie is.
You go back and watch apocalypse now and you're like,
oh,
I like,
oh it's fucking brilliant.
It's pretentious.
But it is really brilliant.
Well for the time,
I don't think it was pretentious.
I think it was bold for the timing.
It was two,
he spent a four,
you know what it was,
I think it costs about 35 million then.
And those days that was considered an obscene amount of money and it didn't have
to take like seven years to make herself.
God,
he took a couple of years to make easily.
Yeah.
And there was a huge delay in Marlon Brando and fucking crazy.
And he got so fat.
They had a film in black from the neck up.
I mean,
what other big name actor,
like Marlon Brando was ever in a movie that's that gigantic and all you see is
his neck up.
They really don't focus on his body much and he still murders it.
Yeah,
he does murders it.
Did you ever see the redux?
There's couple good scenes.
I didn't think they needed to add everything back.
I thought it was better the way it was edited.
But there's a scene with brand new in it were uh,
sort of while they're torturing Martin Sheen and they've got him in like the hot
box,
you know the,
the ever popular bridge on the River Kwai you know?
Yeah.
So he's in a room and they pull the thing up and now the air comes in and,
and Brando surrounded by children and that's the scene.
Like you see it from Martin Sheen's point of view,
the little white square of freedom and Brown does sitting there and he's,
it takes a time magazine.
He goes,
I don't want you to look at this.
And heads of a Time magazine.
It's the most off putting and the Little v,
you know,
Cambodian children are playing and jumping and fucking with Martin Sheen and
he's having to deal with that.
And then Brando's like reading from it says here from Time magazine and third,
well maybe you should have a look at this and you know,
he likes you and more and she needs to read it.
And it's a very strange scene.
It's one of the extra scenes in the,
in the version that I thought was good because you got to see Brando to
something different.
He's is in the sunlight for one thing and he's surrounded by kids to make it
even weirder.
He's not surrounded by warriors.
Yeah,
that's strange because he's talking about the American propaganda about the war
and how he's being portrayed a bet that he's a mad person.
And his point is that the government's mad,
the wars mad.
He's being a sane person in the middle of the mad war by being mad as his,
you know?
Right,
right.
Like,
he cut people's heads off and you know all the things he does in the movie that
you see of the,
the movie was the first movie that was,
that had like the significant impact portraying the psychotic nature of war.
He's an American officer and he's being blamed for being too crazy in the middle
of a war where they're just shooting everyone they meet.
Who's going to go get a Martin Sheen?
Who's doing confluent is underwear,
punching mirrors.
Fucking hotel runs the guy they sent the damaged,
they shut shuttle.
The damaged guy's nuts.
He's a drunk.
Well because he's all he does is kill people for a living.
And now this is the fifth one or whatever in a row.
Cause he says,
have killed four guys.
God Damn,
that's a good movement.
And then so he's,
and then he says,
what are you an assassin?
He goes,
uh,
I'm a soldier.
He says that you're an errand boy.
Sent it,
sent it.
What does it send to?
Collected Storyville for clerks or something like that?
You're an errand boy.
They're all so crazy.
The last time I saw that movie was,
I remember it very clearly because I just got one of those projector things in
my house.
We could see a big ass green,
it was like 80 inches or something.
Oh.
And the sound is fantastic.
Helicopters
flying over your head.
And that was like the first thing that I watched was apocalypse now,
the Redo.
And I was like this,
do you ever see the movie jar?
Jar Head?
Is it the one with Jake Gillen thought didn't see that.
Lots of the Iraq movie.
Right.
And they go to Iraq and good.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
and Jamie Foxx is the tough sergeant and,
and,
and uh,
uh,
um,
what's his name?
Peter Sarsgaard and a JQL and Thaller the sharp shooters,
you know,
they get any in it and they really see some action and this and that.
But they play apocalypse now for the soldiers in that movie because they're all
young.
This is 1991.
It's the first Gulf War.
Right.
And they're imitating the movie.
They're topping the raise and that's on their head like this,
the clips that go in the woods during the Valkyries scene and yet I thought,
well it,
that's their World War II.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That scene where they go in and wipe out the village,
that's their bridge on the river Kwai Wow.
Maybe not soldiers seeking inspiration from movies
about war,
which seems so counterintuitive to the reality of,
well I was watching what some call it the other day,
full metal jacket and,
and that's a real novel called the short timers and it's almost literally
adapted to that movie.
It seems like the movies hyperbole that the guy with the,
I've read the book,
it's about a hundred pages long.
Isn't that just the,
I mean that's like a cliche.
Will you look up the short timers to see who wrote that?
I can never remember the guy's name and full metal jackets.
I don't know if you'd liked full knowledge check and it's two movies,
right?
It's the drill sergeant.
I liked the movie in the,
and then I was going to say is it's Cliche,
life imitating art is like the old cliche,
and this is soldiers imitating soldiers,
right?
I mean they're,
they're learning how to do this war thing based on a movie that they enjoyed
about war.
It's weird,
you know,
obviously they're going through training and obviously they're really going
through water,
but they're also good stuff.
House for getting some inspiration from these films about war,
which is fucking strange.
And then that,
that movie,
uh,
the full metal jacket,
it's not exactly successful in every way.
Cubix really detached filmmaker.
But there was one point,
I thought it was good and it was the biggest,
baddest guy in the unit who's named animal mother.
And he's obviously crazy.
Uh,
and he's mean and all that.
One of the other guys,
one of the other soldiers,
so it's about are marines rather than marines.
He says,
one of the other marine says about him,
you may not believe it,
but when we get into battle,
he's one of the most warmest,
wonderful individuals you'll ever meet in your meaning,
right?
He's,
he kills more guys than any other guy in this unit.
And you want him alive and you want him next to you at all times if we have to
fight cause cause it's going to kill him folks.
And then they keep saying all the marines in the movie keeps saying when we go
back home it's not going to be like this.
They're having like one of the guys says these people that we've killed today or
some of the finest individuals will ever meet,
now we're going to go back to the world and there won't be anybody worth
killing.
Right?
Like cause their world's upside down now they live in a war world.
So everyone that they meet,
they the finest individ they said the finest individuals,
people they kill.
Yeah.
Are there because the meaning of their lives is different in the battle right
there.
They've been trained to kill.
They keep saying in the,
in the marine camp are you a killer over and over and all that.
So I don't know.
That's just a,
you can use warm movies to be moralistic about war.
But at the same time,
there's always the seductiveness of how strange when you put people in a,
in a world of war,
they act like it's a war.
And then that's against the rules of society that we pretend we have.
Like you said,
that we're not just all fucking orcas running around.
Well,
it's very dangerous when you allow people to not conform to those rules to get
thousands of people that you've trained that it's okay to kill folks.
You know?
And that's,
by the way,
that's a trait that they're going to keep.
A lot of them are gonna have a really hard time adjusting.
It's hard.
You've killed a bunch of people and now when they see their friends get killed
for no reason,
sure.
Then the,
you know,
the,
there's some believable,
yeah,
w w we live in,
you know,
a really unusual time because of that,
because we'd never had more information as far as like how damaging wars are
psychologically thou,
how unnecessary they are.
For the most part,
the true financial influence behind the decisions that get made and all that
stuff is so dark and bizarre that when people have to go over there and fight it
and then come back over here,
it's like man,
the world is upside down for them,
you know,
left his right and right is left and nothing fucking make sense at all.
I had a Louis Theroux on the podcast this week,
you know the documentary guy from,
he was talking about hanging out with that a Westboro Baptist church guy and one
of the things that he said that I found fascinating was he went and visited with
these people for three weeks and he said that after a while all their hateful
bile stop being so shocking and it became like almost normal because he was
around.
It's so often that he got like a little Stockholm syndrome a little bit.
Not really like he kept his objectivity,
but he was talking about how the feeling of being around these people,
it had changed what's normal and which is what happens in a war,
but in a much greater sense.
You know,
you chew,
you're changing like not just hurtful thoughts,
but actions that involve killing and it becomes normal.
Oh yes.
Jazz.
And then we blame people and then we arrest people in the middle of wars for
committing atrocities,
which are certainly atrocities but are as much a part of war as anything else.
It's a part of war.
Will.
Dunkin was telling me that someone committed atrocities wise,
they're honest,
mosquito,
um,
thing for a malaria drug.
There's a malaria drug.
Apparently that causes a certain percentage of people that just fucking complete
flip,
flip out.
And some of them get Amnesia and his buddy,
I'm going to get him on my podcast,
I don't know his name,
but Dunkin's buddy lost all of his memory for a good deal of time.
And he was in India and people were talking to him and he had no idea that they
were,
and they arrested him because they thought he was a junkie cars,
but he was really on a malaria medication.
Did he get his memory doc?
He did,
but not all of it.
I think this stuff's called layer IOM.
And this is,
uh,
some,
some stuff that,
you know,
it's just one of those things.
It's how people just have an adverse reaction.
I personally have seen people have an adverse reaction to malaria medicine and
it's fucking weird man,
because it was day Foley who's the sweetest,
nicest,
kindest,
friendliest guy you could ever meet.
He's always nice.
And he was on malaria medication and he had a couple of drinks and I don't know
if it's the mixture of the two or whatever,
but he's like yelling it reporters and he took a risk,
took a reporter's tape recorder out and put it in his drink.
The guy asked him a question,
he goes,
here's your answer.
Blink.
And he put it in his drink.
He was yelling at a guy that was one of the producers and I had to like
physically stand in front of him cause I was worried that he was going like,
go attack someone.
Yeah.
Then the next day he was so apologetic,
he was like,
I'm so sorry.
He absolutely remember it.
Yeah,
he did that medication.
Everyone told them is absolutely that.
It literally makes you Fuku did he,
was he exposed to malaria and the critical there's no,
no,
but he was going to ask,
oh,
he's taking them.
Yeah,
that's terrible.
But,
and this is,
by the way,
this is 1994 five or something like that.
So I don't know what the medication was right that he was on,
but whatever,
this malaria medication wasn't turned him completely wacky.
I saw it in his eyes.
He was,
and he was so apologetic.
I mean it's so out of character for him.
He's not a violent,
it's lovely.
Any stretch of the imagination.
So it was just so,
so to me like proof of concept,
like,
oh look,
you can get a normal nice guy and he becomes this really angry,
almost prone to violence.
Like yeah,
things went totally wrong.
I could have seen him hitting someone with a glass or something like that.
And then the shit hits the fan,
didn't even know what he was doing.
He had no idea what he was doing all because he was on some crazy mind bending
medication.
So for me to see a real Jacqueline Hyde on a guy that I knew fairly well I'd
worked with for a long time and I'd seen him under stress and as he was earlier,
it was always handle things.
You know,
he would never be doing that.
No,
no.
He never snapped and throw someone's tape recorder and it's hearing crane.
Did they just come up with these drugs and they fucking give them to people and
I'm like,
I'm pretty sure it's going to work in my,
I might have some side effects that they do.
Let us know.
We'll be over here,
hear,
get to say real small percentage though,
less than a couple of percent and we're willing to take that.
We're willing to take that hit well,
it's great if you're not one of those people,
if you're not one of the people that goes crazy or if you're one of those people
that takes the medication and doesn't drink,
it might be a drinking thing.
I know I'm Zoloft apparently when,
when mixed with alcohol became a real issue for folks and cocaine,
Zoloft if he makes it with cocaine apparently.
But who would take so long to anchor cocaine on the same night?
Apparently it's pretty common.
People uh,
who are,
you know,
a lot of times people that have drug issues become depressed and uh,
in trying to get off those drugs and not sticking with their plan to get off
those drugs and then you do a real anyway psychotic episode.
Yeah.
You go fuck it.
I just want some coke and just do it.
I dated a girl once who had a coke problem.
It was fascinating.
It was a very strange thing to be around because she's very smart but she
couldn't help it.
She just had to have,
she was working in,
you know,
like studios and she was always around like,
uh,
she was always around like executives,
like agents and things like,
like she worked for agencies and stuff and she just saw all these people,
these parties doing coke.
Cause it was like in the 90s.
Yeah.
Everyone was doing coke and she started doing coke too and just start liking
coke.
You know?
I was like this real weird issue.
You know,
like yeah,
it's always in the back of your head.
You want to get some coke always strongly if that's what you're doing,
that's,
that's pretty much preoccupation.
So if you get off of that stuff and you have a crash with some folks can have
some people when they're trying to cure themselves of a disease,
especially disease of alcoholism or disease of a drug addiction,
they'll often seek help with antidepressants because they feel terrible.
Yeah.
And then fucking they don't,
they don't adhere to the rules.
Right.
They go a little wacky one night,
have a couple of Jack Daniels and then go buy a ball and get crazy and do a rail
and then fucking drive full on,
you know,
90 miles an hour on a fucking residential street and try to hit people you
crazy.
You know,
it's really difficult as it is mixing anything that you know,
twists your mind like,
look,
red bull and vodka is a terrible thing to do cause we're retarded.
It's really,
well,
it's a retarded move.
You're confusing the shit out of your body.
Your body doesn't know if it's on crank or if it's on a downer or Advil unlock
things.
I always feel like your rail,
if you're going to Dell,
that's a Joey Diaz so you could drink more basically until he's so,
he said that.
Do you have get the fuck out of here with this red ball?
He goes,
I do a rail at nine o'clock in the morning like a fucking doctor got up in the
morning.
If you're going to do coke to coke,
you fucking pussy.
I agree.
Oh,
I needed an energy drink.
Don't you fucking coke have some dignity.
I was going to take it.
It's true though.
I was of training a fake soda pop coke drink is to me at night when you're
drinking.
He's like,
well I knew a dude a couldn't get off those monster energy drinks.
Homeboy used to have a giant can with him everywhere he went.
I never,
it was like his cocky,
you know like a cocky,
like a little blankie and carry around with you.
Was He an Aa Guy?
Um,
I noticed a lot of drinking a,
they go crazy on caffeine because then the caffeine caffeine becomes the
substitute for a drink.
Cause at least you're Janky.
You get a feeling off caffeine and that substitutes,
it helps a little bit with the drug wanting.
Yeah.
And cigarettes as well.
They'll give in to the cigarettes bright because you have to have a crutch,
some kind of crutch.
You can't just,
you know,
did you hear that they're going to ban electronic cigarettes?
Oh yeah.
It got approved already.
La You cannot,
you cannot,
you can't do electronic cigarettes in bars.
You can't do them like in public places pretty much.
And why not?
Because people are idiots and they think that this is like,
they don't know what the second hand smoke smoke.
It's vapor and they don't.
Yeah,
it's just idiots.
New York did it and now la just followed suit.
Everybody liked you cigarettes cause you could smoke
should man.
They should.
It doesn't do anything.
It doesn't hurt anybody,
you know,
he doesn't do anything.
So Miss [inaudible] that he's worried about something that's going to hurt
somebody.
People are so god damn crazy.
You should be worried about people's farts before you worried about letting go
into the right lane without speeding up to try to kill me.
Maybe you should do that for me.
That's just where you live,
man.
I'll tell you,
when I lived in Boulder,
Colorado,
I saw more merging than I ever saw my life.
People were so kind about it because it's only 100,000 people and people like,
Hey,
go ahead and get ahead.
You don't even in places like Seattle,
I find much more likely to let you in.
They're driving in slow motion when I get us more polite.
This is a crazy town of everybody trying to get there.
It's so gross though.
And it's the one thing that really moved Greg Proops while we talking.
Shit.
Let's get Outta here,
man.
I'm talking about forming a colony like you and you said [inaudible] of our
friends together.
Let's fucking go somewhere.
I really do.
I need to be,
I love the weather at that.
I mean like other than that I,
we got a bunch of comics to move to a city.
If we picked a city like Seattle and a bunch of comics moved there.
Do you know how,
what an epic move that would be for comedy?
If we just decided we're all gonna get together and we'll open up a comedy club
collective Seattle.
Fuck that.
Why not Seattle's anyway to rainy?
Do you know?
Columbus is one day less rain.
But you know what dude,
you got on the road,
man,
you do comedy on the road.
You just book shit during the winter and like Phoenix and you'll be fine.
Just do a gig every now and then on the road.
You know what you're going appreciate.
You're gonna appreciate cooler,
relax people that are under less pressure.
A lot of intelligent people,
beautiful scenery.
I mean gorgeous trees and lush green forests because they get so much moisture.
The number one problem we have in California is that we don't get enough.
No,
I'd rather do it.
Denver.
Portland is a good move to Portland.
Denver's Denver's the best.
They have great food and good wine and good weed.
They have all the civilized things that I think make places nice.
And like you say,
it's the show business because I was noticing like a,
you know Harold Ramis,
he passed,
he moved back to Chicago at too.
His parents never had,
and I remember reading a quote from him when he passed the,
one of the articles about him said,
he goes,
uh,
I'm number one here man.
He goes,
other than the key Sachs,
I'm the biggest thing in this neighborhood.
And that made me laugh my ass off.
And I thought,
but you're right.
Right.
Like he didn't do it for that reason.
But when you go back to the hood,
he's here.
He's still Harold Ramis,
the director and writer.
He just didn't want to be in harder.
Yeah.
You don't have to be,
you know,
you don't,
it's not necessary when you get to a certain level,
I think at any level anymore.
I mean,
not as much love much on the road.
A mile mean like we're on the road.
I am,
but I really do love that my friends are here.
That's the big one.
The big one is all the comics that we know that here we do that we have this
giant community.
It's amazing.
Like we do these ice house shows on Wednesday nights,
like 10:00 PM shows him then we're probably gonna do next Tuesday or if we can
and they,
they're fucking the most fun you could ever have.
We're hanging out with Brian.
Callan is doing them when bill's bill burrs done them,
Joey Diaz and all these different people are doing them and everyone's having a
great time.
Brian's done.
I'm a bunch of times and Duncan's done on a bunch of times and when we,
you know,
it's not just a hang out,
everybody's in town were all hanging out together.
We'll get like five,
six friends together and we're laughing and having fun and going up in front of
great crowds.
That's hard to move away from.
Yes,
that's hard.
All the comics are hard.
Everything else can go fuck itself.
Get all the comics,
just everybody get out of your mortgage and figure out a way to get to Denver.
All of us.
I do love some of the venues and I do love the crowds and I like you said,
did I,
you know,
you're able to eke out a little existence for yourself here and an identity and
have the thing go on.
And then a big shark pool like this,
that's a really important to have that.
But say if you did a weekly show,
it's like you say the other shit really not worth all up my wiener.
Not Worth it.
Dealing with those people,
it's not worth it.
There's too many in the [inaudible].
What does everybody want?
What is it you want wealth and shit.
They want to fill a hole.
They want us to get validation.
They want to be an it person.
I dated a girl once who was an actress at the last one and it was pulling away
and uh,
she actually said it to me.
She,
you know,
I was talking about the devils rag.
Hollywood report him.
I don't read that Shit.
That shit's bad for you.
I go,
you're just going to be looking at all these people.
Why didn't I get that?
How come I didn't move up?
So I go,
they just got tagged your it like you can't connect yourself to that.
Somebody got tagged,
they got lucky.
I got lucky.
I got on TV.
There's no reason for me to be on TV when I was on TV,
right?
Anybody else could have done an adequate or better job.
I just got lucky and these people were freaking her out and she goes,
when am I going to be it?
When am I going to be at?
What am I going to get tagged?
What?
Sometimes it doesn't happen,
right?
And that's not you.
That fucking dead,
dead drives people crazy.
That drives people fucking crazy.
It's one of the reasons why everyone's so nuts here is because the,
the idea that you have no control over your own destiny and you need a bunch of
people to decide whether or not they're going to cast you in like you.
And the only reason you would put yourself in that position,
the first place you have this massive debt,
your,
your childhood,
something went wrong.
You just,
and extraordinary amounts of attention.
So just combine those two things.
The need for extraordinary amounts of attention and your life being based on
other people's acceptance.
That's why you get a bunch of phony fucks.
A bunch of people just parroting the shift that they read on salon.com and what
are the left wing rhetoric that they've heard this dispute by or dispensed by
intelligent people and they just repeat those things without even thinking about
it.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that here.
There's a lot of nonsense here.
A lot of pretend people that aren't even,
they don't even know who they are.
They even have opinions.
They've adopted a conglomeration of other people's opinions because they think
that'll let them get a fucking sitcom that'll get them in at the next CSI,
you know,
interview fuck.
But it's also really cool because it's so surreal here.
Like,
like you know,
I was at Starbucks the other day and Wil Wheaton was in front of me and it's
like the motherfucking stand by me guys right there.
I grew up with this kid and then t and then the Toronto Mayor Crack Mayor was at
the comedy store getting drunk with everyone.
The other,
of course.
Why didn't you call me
La Jolla?
Oh my God.
I would go to the comedy store to hang out with rob for whatever nanny Ikea's
course.
You went to the store.
The store is a fucking vortex for crazy people.
It's sucks them in like a magnet,
a little iron sheet that says,
fuck.
Yeah,
it does.
When Brian and I were there all the time,
we used to film there.
We met the most bizarre people,
people that thought that there was the second coming of Christ.
We met prostitutes that told us exactly how they went about their business.
Everybody film,
they didn't care.
They're just crazy people in that spot.
He was partying.
Every comic got a photo with him.
Austin,
so that's so awesome.
Is He gone now?
Yeah.
He left out yesterday after being on Jimmy Kimmel,
which I don't know if you heard what happened.
I do know that after the show ended,
he was pissed off at what happened on Jimmy Kimmel and what could he possibly be
pissed off about?
Jimmy smoke crack.
He gets drunk all the time and he talked about that.
He didn't eat,
say wanting to eat a girl's pussy during a press conference.
He's a fucking mayor.
You're not a comedian dude.
He can't say shit like that.
Did you see his appearance on the show?
No,
I didn't see it.
No.
I don't check it out though.
It's,
it's like he's just,
he's just a sad case.
It's the,
the people got screwed.
Okay.
The people,
Toronto don't think this is a God damn joke cause their entire city,
one of the great cities in the fucking three municipality in North America,
he's their man.
It's a God damn awesome city.
Toronto is the shit.
Could you imagine if your city was being represented by some obese crackhead?
Yeah.
Which is what he is and he's seedless,
he's an obese,
dense,
crack head who sucks at communicating.
And the worst one is there's a video of him coked up talking about how he's
going to beat some guy up there.
He's going to be like Mike Tyson and they're talking about like,
do you want to fight them MMA?
Like how many minutes you need,
like five minutes.
Or I could do five minutes.
Like,
he's like,
he's so coked up.
He's like pacing back and forth talking about,
you know,
like you don't know me.
He doesn't know me.
I'm crazy.
I'll beat the shit out of him.
I'll fucking charge one.
But he's all,
this is a fucking mayor or you're a mayor.
Millions of people.
Uh,
your responsibility talking like a drunk teamster.
You know what I mean?
He's crazy.
Well,
they weren't,
I mean,
I've been up there a bunch of the sheer,
and they're,
they're not thrilled about it.
I shouldn't be using,
obviously they find it easy.
They have to,
but it's fair.
They have this amazing fucking city.
It's amazing.
And the most amazing cities,
there's a Turd floating around in it.
It's fun.
They can't get him out,
man.
They try it and you they're do nice up there.
They're do.
Nice.
Could you imagine if that guy was a mayor of a city in Russia?
Less.
Yeah,
Canada is the anti Russia don't really nice,
but he's kicking ass though.
As a mayor.
Is he doing well?
Really?
Well that's what the problem does.
See,
I would like to read that because,
uh,
the things that I hear from Toronto people online are not positive at all.
I'm hearing that he's a terrible mayor,
but I dunno man.
Maybe a guy needs a little break.
It needs a little break poo.
Oh,
come to La and do Jimmy Kimmel and then get mad at Jimmy Kimmel.
Well,
I'm saying,
you know,
maybe smoking a little crack is something that could do all mayors a little.
Do you do it?
I think,
well,
there's only been two that have ever been caught Marion Marian,
him.
So,
um,
I tend to agree with you because that's enough of a sample group that doesn't
want to say all.
You're going to use that to represent the right.
If each mayor represents all the mayors.
I would say that that's all the mayors I met Marion Barry and I asked him about
the crack sound,
the opie and Anthony Show.
And uh,
I pulled him in,
he was walking down the hallway and I was on the opiate Anthony Show where we
were like,
Holy Shit,
that's Mary and Barry.
So we went out and I go,
let's get him,
let's get him.
And then the publicist like didn't know what to do because we asked him to be on
like,
it wasn't scheduled beyond right.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
he sitting down and me and Anthony and Oop,
we're,
we're drilling him and asking him questions and I was like,
did you really smoke crack?
And then hotel was,
nobody knows who it was cracking that pipe.
He goes,
I saw
he was hilarious.
He goes,
nobody knows that those cracking me up.
I'm like,
Damn,
you got me?
But you didn't say you didn't smoke crack,
which is what I would say if you said,
hey,
Joe Rogan,
do you smoke crack at a hotel?
I'm like,
no,
I didn't smoke crack in a fucking hotel.
But he's like,
nobody knows who it was cracking that plan.
And I was like,
whoa,
that's some genius double legal talk.
Wow.
I was just [inaudible] he said yes.
Oh yeah.
He said,
well,
it's a disgrace.
I'm very sorry.
I feel embarrassed,
but we're going to have to move on.
Yeah.
I need to run the city for Toronto is brilliant people living in it.
Three years ago I was there and uh,
or,
oh it's in Montreal and,
and he,
that was when he flipped off the little girl,
I don't know if you remember that.
Oh,
he flipped off a little girl.
He's just,
you know,
he's just stopped that bull in a China shop.
He pulled out that alive in a lady and,
and you know,
he's trying to get around her and he went like this and shipping out a kid in
the car with her.
And then it was her,
cause it's Canadian TV,
you know,
they interviewed her on CBC and like she,
she's like,
when I was driving and he get you this stuff and like I still had that.
It was moved forward and then he,
he know he made this signal to me and my daughter was there in the front seat
and she saw it as well and he drove off and you know,
you're like,
you know,
she ain't lion.
She's just a little by late Canadian person.
And he took,
they are the nicest people in the world.
A couple
of blasts and the bathroom was like,
no,
he didn't.
He was huffy and he liked it going lady move that he had a slice of Pepperoni.
I got shit to do.
I got to hook her.
I got to go beat up or whatever.
I'm feeling a little sleepy.
I'm just going to do a quick line.
I gotta I gotta get back to the office and make new traffic agendas.
Yeah.
I got a couple,
I've got a couple of calls I got to take.
What a weird time for the guy,
like a guy like that to be a mayor.
They were having a tickle,
tickle wars.
That's how they don't tell each other secrets.
They tickle each other until they wind up coming each other's mouths.
That's what starts,
it starts with tickling.
That's how they do it.
That's how they get,
that's how they recruit you.
That's what Canadian military,
that's tickling the,
that's how they make people talk.
They typically don't give you a pink ballet.
Very painful.
Yeah,
and these guys,
they just,
it's a diversion of that and they,
they typically each other till the lower each other.
He just probably eating a lot of food.
He's eating a lot of food,
unbelievable amounts of food.
Tried to put him on a diet to it and then,
well he probably can't even think straight.
It's probably digesting food all the time.
And that's why he needs to do coke.
Yeah.
Just to fucking little pick me up.
You know,
he's probably always on the wall because your body's like that.
You're not gluten free.
I'll tell you that.
Great acclaim free.
He's not gluten free.
He's not barbecue free.
He's probably just dealing with all these clogs shit and his body,
of course he has.
And so he can't think straight.
And he really has an obligation to take care of those people in Toronto and he
loves them and cares for them dearly.
So because of that,
he does a little bump here and there to give himself a little pick me up so we
can get the job done better.
A lot of people that don't understand that though,
they misconstrue and they think he's a drunken buffoon,
that it's just a big fat embarrassment.
He's not.
What he's doing is he's sacrificing his own public image for the job.
I see.
He's doing,
he's doing what he's got to do.
I'd like to believe is responsible.
If I did coke,
you would think I was trying to get a line off him.
I was going to say the way you're talking right now,
you can be honest PR stuff.
I could convince myself in almost anything.
I convinced myself into big foot for several years.
I could convince myself that might exist.
Mary,
2012 which one?
Oh,
December 21st I was committed by having a license plate was December,
2012.
Oh uh,
the end of the Mayan calendar.
The calendar is the end of the long count of the Mayan calendar.
I always subscribed to the long count calendar theory and that the snake God is
coming.
You know what I,
I was listening to this Mckenna lecture the other day,
never said it.
That was my favorite part of that whole theory.
No,
they never did.
They never stood up and went by the way it's over.
It was just the end of a cycle.
Just like January goes into February.
I mean,
it was,
it wasn't one,
they built their calendar so perfectly that it was a perpetual cycle.
So I was re listening to this Mckenna lecture and it was really fascinating
because he was,
uh,
talking about the,
the Mayan language being something called the reverse language,
which means that the,
the symbols and his loss language,
they represent sounds.
They don't represent things or they repor like say like,
like,
uh,
no,
they represent things not sounds.
That's what it is.
So like there was a symbol for an eye and there's a symbol for a saw cutting
wood and this is a symbol for a rose and it was all right and an aunt like a bug
in it.
That would be how you would say I saw aunt rose,
like that's their language.
So the language is incredibly complicated to try to interpret of course,
because we don't know what the fuck anything meant.
Right.
Unlike glyphs,
which represents sound,
right,
like or his or her,
you know,
t play these things with my kids in the car.
T is the ta sound letters,
sound hold down.
It's cute,
it's very cute.
But they didn't have that.
They didn't,
didn't represent sounds that represented things.
So it was really fucking confusing to try to like interpret.
So a lot of people's versions of what the Mayan calendar set or man,
they're all fucking screwy.
They're like,
they're still working on that stuff.
Like every now and then they have these big breakthroughs,
these Rosetta stone moments.
But it's a very difficult time finding more and more minds stuff all the time.
And there's also zillions of minds here in southern California.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yeah.
People go where the mines were good.
They were,
they became Mexicans.
And if you go down where they go,
you can,
you can see them all over the streets.
Well,
if you go to the Yucatan,
especially,
you could go like near the mine temples that she needs.
So you see people with a very different look,
very Mayan native American look very different and pronouncedly different and
they're fucking tiny man.
I was going to say they're four foot nine.
There's so small.
There was a woman,
um,
that I,
I mean I'm short,
I'm five,
eight and this woman was literally be like breast height to me.
She was like one of those little hobbit people almost,
you know,
one of those homo floresiensis be that I was really like strange.
And they all sell artifacts to Gringos Mayan artifacts.
You know,
whether by these ancient structures that someone in their ancestry built,
no one knows how fascinating fucking shit.
Oh,
representing the cosmos in,
you know,
in alignment with different constellations and exacting as if there a choice in
it astronomically.
Perfect.
Calendar and more perfect than any European calendar.
Oh yeah.
And it's also,
it's the,
when they look at these structures and they look at the complexity in them and
they try to figure out where the stones all came from and what kind of fucking
knowledge these people must have had to be able to,
there's no shitty construction.
No.
Like,
you know,
you ever have a carpenter come to your house and he'd do a shit job of making
this fucking thing line up.
But that thing,
and it's not level,
it's,
there's a gap over here.
You see amazing symmetry in stone,
beautiful geometric patterns that if you,
you know,
you made all these stones,
if you were off like an inch or an inch there,
by the time you got to the top would be all fucked up and sideways.
But no,
these things are beautiful.
No.
Yeah.
And we don't know how they did it.
We don't get unbelievable engineers.
Yeah.
Incredible.
And we're talking about no mortar to yeah,
they're just stones.
Like they,
that's the interesting fitted him.
Yeah.
That's the interesting facet about them.
It's like clearly they were very advanced,
but also clearly very primitive.
There's things that they,
that we have figured out that they hadn't,
well,
they didn't have candles evidently.
Well,
they weren't a fossil fuel economy.
They weren't a fossil fuel civilization.
What they were and what Egypt is,
is as far as a civilization gets without combustion,
without fossil fuels and engines,
they figure out this alternative path.
It's like human innovation is not subject to the rules that we've experienced in
our life.
This is just one way to go.
When you look at the way the Mayans went and he looked at the way the Egyptians
went,
what they did is like the dolphin thing,
like they can change their environment the way we can,
you know,
today.
So what they did was they figured out a way to do it with natural items.
They figured out a way to express themselves in this advanced way without the
tool.
So where's the dolphins don't have thumbs.
They didn't have machines or stainless steel.
So they fought somehow or another figured out a way to make clearly they had
mathematically per,
yeah.
Without her.
Then they had astronomy and philosophy and,
and they had history that we can't fathom.
We can,
we even can't even wrap our heads around the idea of a thousand years of
history.
If we get about 200030004000 the Egyptians were in that location for a long
fucking time and they were writing shit down that we'll never get to read
because of the light of the fires of the library of Alexandria.
So it's weird.
That is such an unbelievably fascinating culture.
Oh,
unbelievably.
Because it's what happens when you don't have the fossil fuels.
What would we do without oil?
We would maybe have pyramids.
We've figured out how to make that.
We would have gone another way.
We'd have gone this way if we couldn't figure it out.
They didn't sail all over the world.
Well,
there's evidence that they did,
right?
Yeah.
It's disputed.
Apparently.
I talked about it before that someone from Egypt,
they found cocaine in Egypt that could have only been grown in South America,
but then someone sent me hip to a link that it might have been a false positive
based on cocaine,
like plants that existed in the Egypt at that time.
That wasn't,
we underestimate the ancients.
That's all I'm saying.
I think that they did have the ability to go around the world if people were
able to populate all the Polynesia and those mile islands,
you're thousands of miles apart.
But you know,
they figured that out too.
There was a documentary or a,
um,
a docu drama about it,
uh,
from some strange name was a foreign film.
I just watched it the other day.
Me and Ari watched it where they,
in Peru,
they got on a boat and they sailed all the way across to the South Pacific.
Kon Tiki did that for the 14.
That's it.
That's the movie.
Yes.
Kon Tiki.
That's exactly what it is.
This is,
and he said that they were related to south sea islanders and the people of
South America.
Interesting movie.
So there's a couple of cut the shit moments in it.
They kill a shark and bring it up on the fucking bar charts all the time in the
book,
but they pick it up and bring it to this like giant shark.
It's so big that it's so obviously like Photoshop be like,
come on man.
Do you know how much that fucking thing would way?
First of all,
you can't just pull out on your raft,
asshole.
It's going to tip over your raft.
Right?
You can't just stab it in the head and kill you.
It's going to flop around.
It's a fish fuck face.
All right.
It's a shark,
but it's a fish.
You can't just pull a shark on the deck there.
Giant man.
They fucking huge.
And the book,
they're doing it all the time.
He said they played with them and stuff.
Well,
I bet they did,
but I bet they were small,
smaller problems.
There's no way it was that big.
Yeah.
The one that they used in the movie was so preposterous.
It was a fucking missile.
There's even evidence that black Africans came over to the south and that I can,
stuff like that.
They don't really chase that stuff down as hard as they can.
Also,
uh,
the water levels change so much.
A lot of things are underground that warrant 10,000 years ago or underwater.
So the coastlines of changed,
I think that dramatically.
And people live near the water.
So that's,
I think that not only that they're saying now that they think that people were
trapped in a landmass on the Bering strait for thousands of years,
that it wasn't a smooth transition between people coming,
walking over,
like shown,
walking over.
People got stranded out there for thousands of years.
Yeah.
I mean there was nowhere to go and everything.
The environment changed.
The earth moved on them,
the earth moved on.
Yeah.
And they got stuck,
you know,
and then there's the old mex who they don't even know who the fuck they were.
Right.
And they have these African faces that are carved into these giant stones that
they're guesstimating.
It's somewhere around 6,000 years ago.
They really,
yeah.
They don't even know.
The mines were like,
what,
1500 years ago,
2000 years ago.
But the old Mex,
he didn't even know anything about them.
They don't anything about their language.
They don't know the,
there are no so little.
So it's like the chase that down like what do you do?
And then there's what they say about all those fucking theirs.
They're finding on a regular basis in Mexico City,
they do construction and they find temples,
the dig into the ground.
I'm like,
Whoa,
hold up,
hold up.
We just hit gold.
Okay.
We found a gold castle,
like they find crazy shit on a regular basis.
And then when they're going through the jungles,
especially at the Amazon,
there was a whole thing.
I was watching a documentary on lost civilizations in the Amazon where they had
found these,
um,
these,
uh,
like paths,
like creeks that had been carved into the ground,
aqueducts or what have you.
They found this complex irrigation system that was built into these like unknown
jungle areas.
Right.
And they were like,
what the fuck is this?
And then there was a mound of,
they figured out was actually a construction of some sort and they thought it
was just a hill,
but the hill had existed for so long,
had been covered up with dirt and then became like,
you know,
let's just to fucking sell made that hell.
Yeah.
And they're looking at this like,
no,
no.
This at one point in time somebody built this,
like we're finding pottery and weird shit.
And then you look at it from a satellite,
you could actually see grids.
They started like finding grids with seismic readings and they'd use,
uh,
you know,
um,
there's all sorts of different ways they send radio waves into the ground.
Right.
I know.
Isn't that amazing how they can find the grids underneath things now?
Incredible structure.
But they'll like,
who was doing this?
Who,
who's shit is this?
Who are these people that live there now or don't live like,
right.
No,
they're,
they,
they've,
it's primitive.
This are much more primitive than those people were much more.
I mean,
and it's ironic that you see these people and it's really primitive environment.
You see them with like a Hanes,
his tee shirt on.
Right,
of course.
Because we've poisoned the entire world.
Yeah.
There's no more,
people don't make their own clothes.
We the third world where's all of our jetter Tennyson.
Yeah.
There's also the descent of man to,
I mean if you think about it that way,
the ancient Egyptians in the Mayans possess knowledge that we don't possess and
it does that mean we're more advanced than them because we have a phone and we
can check,
start douchebag friends.
I don't think it does.
I think they knew about the moon and the stars and the movement of the world and
maybe wouldn't have either been is panicked about.
So obviously natural disasters wiped them out in a lot of cases.
They're always talking about that with the Mayans was,
was it drought,
was it earthquake,
was it that forced them to move that forced them to change the thing that I
think they all sought to alter their environment.
There's none of this benign,
I live with nature under relief.
That's primitive.
People like you.
I say it in if you have any intellection all or any inhibition or any kind of
um,
you know,
gumption or anything that motivates you to is curiosity.
The Mayans farmed fish,
the mind's irrigated,
the mine's burned out.
Jungles.
The mines built giant things in the middle of other things.
They didn't live in harmony.
Like we like to think like,
oh,
they lived with a buffalo and they walked around.
They always seem to alter,
not only altered the universe they live in to interpret the physical universe as
it relates to them always.
And uh,
that's,
I think that's what people are and that kind of gets lost in the excitement of
having high technology and instantaneous communication and stuff is that if
they'd had it,
they would have employed it.
Like you said,
they went as far as they could without oil.
Uh,
if to give the mines electricity or the,
or the Egyptians,
let them have light at night,
let them have ultra powerful telescopes and space probe.
Yeah,
no kidding.
I mean,
they probably had the same ingenuity and minds that we had.
They just had your watching the plan to work with.
They're watching the cosmos,
they're trying to figure out the natural world and how cycles when and build
here so that they didn't get it
flooded and you know when you think about how much advancement they did have in
those areas as areas of construction using natural materials and what an
indication that is of extreme intelligence,
we assume with brass chisels and having to exploit the natural fissures and
rocks and having to be engineers of the highest caliber or not,
and Brion pull up an image of the Mayan calendar,
pull up a stone image,
find a good one because this the Mayan calendar,
it's like,
okay.
I mean I had an old joke about how few people understand technology of this is
if I gave you a hatchet and left you in the woods,
how long would it take for?
You could send me an email that no one knows any of this shit.
How long would it take for you to ever figure out all the cycles of the earth
itself so that you could create this fucking countless eternity,
this fucking thing,
that piece of art,
which is more accurate than any western counties?
There's no leap years.
No,
those are included.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Like you say,
the three counts,
they have the three cycles.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's,
it's,
and it,
it,
it's one of those things that like the Yugas,
like the Kali Yoga,
the ages of man,
it takes into account ages where people kind of took into account the rise and
fall of civilizations in their calendars as if it was off like sort of a
mathematical algorithm like the indies.
They,
the Hindus,
they thought that there was a mathematical program to like life on earth that
you would reach these ages of enlightenment and they would be followed by
darkness and it would be despair.
And then there'd be a rebirth.
Like there's a yin and a Yang,
a breathing in and breathing out at tide goes in.
The tide goes out with everything including civilization.
Not always forward movement,
but that that would be worked a calendar that would be [inaudible] agreed upon.
Not just as folklore.
No,
no,
no.
But think about the amount of religion of data that they would have to possess
for them all to agree on it.
Thousands and thousands of years of collected wisdom and watching planets in
retrograde watching cycles in motion.
Fuck.
We can't even wrap our hands around that.
We can't.
We just can't.
Where do we think all the belief systems came from that we supposedly believe in
like two days and then Christianity and I don't want that on my balls.
That is,
Oh,
you can have that on your left,
right.
Ball Center taint is that guy Joe mode.
Imagine the first time you ever dated a girl and she goes down.
Yeah,
and that's what she sees tattooed around your asshole.
She'd be like,
Oh,
cabaret back.
That's a deal breaker.
Yeah.
It is tattooed assholes or I can't go.
Well,
it's a bold aesthetic choice.
Yeah.
You can have a star on your forehead.
I'll let it slide.
Wow.
Pretty good idea.
Took right tattoo.
It's well,
you'd have to have someone who's a very talented artist.
I would be comfortable with,
say like an analytical one,
right to Mayan calendar,
tattoos,
Erin Dellavedova or a Kat von d.
They would,
they would be able to
do that.
Well,
I'll say that the cultural significance of everything they did too.
They didn't just play sports to play sports.
Obviously they did just to amuse themselves,
but when they're having their big games,
those are an expression of,
as you were saying,
the Cozaar gruffy the university,
they were reenacting the moments of the universe.
That's why it was played for life and death
and all that.
I don't mean every day they didn't take for life and death,
but when they have their rituals,
you don't like the original Olympic Games were an Olympics because that was a
spiritual place and that's where all the temples were and it started as a small
event and then eventually became a unifying event for all of Greece or what they
call ionic know,
Hellenic culture,
whatever.
But that's because it was a spiritual to play the Games was to be part of this
ongoing thing that went on and on.
It wasn't,
you know what I mean?
We win this sheer hurray for us.
You know,
obviously there's that moment of it,
but also you went there at a sacrifice.
She went there to sing,
you went there to pray,
you went there to be with everyone else.
People pitched up and camped.
It was a giant event and people came from,
it took a long time to get someplace then,
cause they didn't have a bus that took you there.
You had to get there.
And when you got there,
you didn't stay at a hotel.
You stayed in the field and you,
you know,
but yet they still had these giant organized games and you see the crowns from
them and you see the grounds.
They,
when they had the Olympics in Greece,
they played on lots of the original fields from Co,
you know,
of over a thousand years ago.
And imagine if there's a continuity of man,
you know that the imagining of what you can,
you know,
why did you have your discus thrower and you're in that arena.
Those days there was discus throwers thousands of years ago standing in your
very footsteps.
Yeah.
Or Javelin wouldn't put,
there's a bunch of events.
They rode horses more and they rustled a lot.
And when they,
when they long jump,
they held weights,
they held weights when you could run and then,
or a standing long jump Wu and I just punched it and you,
but you held weight so you could go further.
You can go further with weights.
Yeah.
If you,
if you have like two 10 pound weights in your hands and you fling yourself
forwards it with the weights.
Drinks.
Yeah.
And so they fought,
they didn't work gloves but they wrap their hand bugs bunny shit.
Like when you step out of a plane hits the ground,
right?
Yeah.
Now that it's all very,
and that's the thing that I think that why we like sports on TV and why people
like religion still.
If they do,
there's very little ritual left in our lives,
right,
and it's very little community ritual.
Like in a mind culture.
When you woke up in the morning,
you didn't just go,
I wonder what I'm going to do today.
The drums went off before dawn,
the priests started singing the sun was song into existence.
Yet again on another day.
At the end,
Sisense was burned.
You went to school.
If you were a child or you went to your job,
your life was ritualized and your life was codified and your life was it.
You were in a bar.
You know,
you had to do what you had to do every day.
And those cultures,
that's how they were able to have high culture with pyramids and and
engineering.
They didn't just fucking wander around like we do and go,
I'm going to get high and fucking watch deputy dog and fucking,
you know,
Netflix,
my ass off all day.
Whenever I went.
Deputy dog eat dog.
I love it.
I went deputy dot.
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
that's the difference.
People built the pyramids,
the people that built the pyramids in Egypt were paid in beer and bread and
whatnot,
and lived in camps near the pyramids with their families.
And there were foremans and there were workers and there were people of every
level and they had to fit into their society.
They weren't a disorganized rabble and they weren't all slaves being whipped to
do this.
They were,
yeah,
they thought they were motivated.
They knew about eternity.
Eternity was a real thing.
The new by their diets,
the diets showed that they were,
um,
that they were skilled workers.
Yup.
And that beer is a,
is a,
is a nutritious food as well as,
I didn't tweet this,
we've been alive this whole time with,
I cheated in the beginning,
but I should probably go pretty soon to you.
Uh,
Greg,
I've got a parent that I'm working on.
You got a pyramid.
Just finished lacing the laying the base stones,
but I think they're off back couple of centimeters and I'm going to be real
trouble when I get those Mayan workers these days.
Dude,
you got to watch them every step of the way.
They get on cheap booze.
They,
um,
when they did like examinations of the,
the camp sites,
they found like really expensive foods like chicken bones and you know,
like that,
you know,
meats that are expensive.
So they knew that these people weren't slaves.
These people were still skilled workers.
That's how you now they're not eating chitlins the really nutty numbers and when
you break down how long it would take to build one,
the Great Pyramid of Giza is 2 million,
300,000 stones.
So if you cut and place 10 stones a day,
it would you 664 years.
We don't know.
We don't know how long it
took them,
but that pyramids were old.
What do they say?
The age of Cleopatra,
which is 2000 ish ears.
Right.
Uh,
to us,
cause she was alive when Julio Caesar was alive and she lived til what,
1980 or something.
Uh,
or,
or BC right before a d or CE as they say now.
Um,
is closer to us than she was to the pyramids.
Yeah.
Isn't that incredible?
The parameds.
We're so old when Cleopatra,
the last of the pharaohs was existent.
But then did you see that other day,
and I'm sure you saw this,
John Tyler,
the president from the 1840s two grandchildren alive.
Grand Children,
not great grandchildren,
not great,
great grandchild ran.
He had kids like late into his sixties he had kids,
very old and with two different women who are quite younger than him.
And then they had their kids had kids when they were very old.
Here's,
that's how it's only two bloody generations to go back to before the civil war.
God Nest,
they're old.
They're in their late eighties early nineties but it's still,
think about the [inaudible].
That's what you know,
like you said,
the ancientness of the,
how would you be able to build a pyramid like that?
Well,
if you had zillions of workers,
well organized,
well fed,
and if in a,
in a,
a benefit,
a society that was able to produce that kind of access,
that you were able to feed that many people and put on a giant project like
that.
And,
and they're not even the first one's right there,
the third or fourth incarnation appearing right.
Cause there's the one that stepped pyramid first,
and then the other one,
you know,
they don't even think that now there's,
there's no,
there's a very controversial,
uh,
theories involving the ages and the variations and the ages.
And there's,
there's some stuff that they've uncovered that is like the same methods of
construction that they used,
uh,
like with the,
the Sphinx Temple.
So one of the reasons why they want to backdate the Sphinx Temple,
the really the John Anthony West and the Robert Schoch sees the geologists and
they want to keep resonating.
They want it back.
Well,
there's evidence for it now because of go Beckley tappy,
which is that civilization they found in Turkey.
That's giant,
massive stone columns,
concentric circles.
And it's 14,000 years old.
And they're like,
Holy Shit,
because we are,
when you're talking about the pyramids,
you're talking about 5,000 plus years ago.
Yeah.
2,500 BC.
Think about that.
So from then back,
just from then back,
you're talking about an additional 9,000 years.
Jesus fucking Christ,
and they were able to have high technology that's 5,000 years from us,
which we presume the years before them,
so almost doubled the time between us and the construction of the pyramids.
Back to go back.
Lee Tapping.
Yeah.
Wow.
So that means they had writing belief systems,
agriculture.
They have the technology make
giant stone structure,
which is the real mind blower because that was what it was always argued about.
The backdating of the Sphinx.
They would like what civilization existed because they trying to,
John Anthony West,
Robert Schoch,
we're trying to say that there's erosion marks.
Robert Schoch is a geologist and he said there is clear water erosion marks all
over the temple.
The Sphinx were,
the blocks were cut out.
The last time there was significant rainfall and the Nile Valley was 9,000 BC.
So you would need thousands of years of rainfall previous to that.
So you're talking eleven thousand ten thousand BC,
which is holy fucking shit.
That man looks alive.
That's twelve thousand thirteen thousand years ago.
That's the pleistocene.
That's 72 cats.
Let's get a say.
There's giant animals still.
We're making sphinxes.
They were making these temples,
they were building complex patterns in stone.
Then the,
the,
the old kingdom stuff they find like buried deep,
deep,
deep in the ground is this older version of construction that doesn't have
hieroglyphs on it and it's still massive stone structures but cut into more
distinct pattern of larger stones.
So the variations in the,
in the models and the way they built him,
there's a lot of people that think they might have gotten less advanced as time
went on and a lot of the shitty pyramids,
what might've been like later Pharaoh's they're like,
build me a magnificent.
And they were like,
uh,
don't how to do it anymore.
We lost the cold.
The numbers get a Janky contractors out there fucking slap it together.
Some shitbag pyramid and people are trying to say that these are the first
pyramid.
Well,
they might not be.
You're right.
It's hard to backdate stone.
You know,
they,
they take like little organic bits in between the stones and things that are
buried near the stones,
but you know,
they're pretty sure the Great Pyramid of Giza,
2,500 BC pretty sure,
and it didn't come out of nowhere.
No giant engineering feat that's still standing.
I think I need to go there.
I'm scared because of the civil unrest there.
John Anthony West says,
don't worry about it.
It's nothing we do that my wife keep having this discussion.
We keep wanting to go from crystals.
That's the place to go,
man.
That's the motherfucker all motherfucker.
That's the big mind fuck of civilization.
These,
the big spotted,
they do that 2 million,
300,000 stones the way between the two and some of them way up to as much as 80
tons and the intricacy of what's inside and beneath it.
The whole complex,
the whole system around there.
And then there's things that they're like the 10 that were covered.
Of course they're covered with beautiful limestone in the gold cap and they use
that limestone to build some little patches of it.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a mind fuck.
Yeah,
I was gonna say the query it,
they basically just quiet.
The parents.
Assholes came along and destroyed one of the greatest structures known to man
and it's still there.
It's so big butt down.
I don't,
I don't think you can appreciate that unless you're there.
I got to go there,
but I don't want to limit it to two.
I would just love it if somehow there,
but you know what the price is now our trip.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
We were on the other night the other day and they're like,
it's things that would've cost you a fortune before,
like half price,
but then you have to be able to deal with getting out of there.
If you were Anthony Bordain,
you just fly in and out of fucking Bat Cape.
He got it goes all these fucking crazy places.
He goes to Libya,
he goes everywhere and he just takes that risk and just go.
It's a small crew to,
or four ps.
One.
If you're by yourself,
if a war breaks out,
you're fucked.
A doodle do,
then that's the thing about taking your family.
Yes.
Well,
he goes Solo.
He doesn't bring his family,
but he went to Beirut and war broke out and do you remember that episode?
Episode,
man,
that upset mother fucker.
That was crazy.
And then how do you get out?
You can't.
You've got to wait it out.
And you,
who knows if your hotel is going to get here,
who knows how extreme it is going to get?
Yeah.
Who knows who has a nuke?
Who's gonna?
Who's gonna read I rocket launch you fucking rental car scraped proofs.
But you know,
we do know you're not going to get nuked.
If you go to Greg proops.com and pick up your special at Musso and Frank's,
you're not going to get nuked,
folks.
This is actually protection against nuked.
We can say that with 100% money back guarantee payable only to the people who
got nuked.
You know why?
Because if you get nuked,
you're fucking,
you never going to collect and now you're never going to class.
You're going to be a warm enveloping glow of humor and good attitude.
It's n I n clad guarantee.
Greg Proops.
It's not even disingenuous.
I told me I was crazy to sell it for $4 but she couldn't stop me.
She can't stop hearing you are.
You are men and that control.
You're a a man who's got the balls to film his comedy special at a restaurant.
A restaurant on the floor.
Yeah.
It gives zero fucks.
There's no stage now.
There wasn't.
There's no makeup.
There's a jazz band though.
Oh,
well that's nice.
It's nice to have jazz band.
I wish I had of jasmine.
That's when you're real gangster.
You've got your own barber and a jazz band.
I now a barbarous waiting for you.
His full time job is waking every day.
That's what I love about the old days.
Every day a shaving us gentle trim.
Hey Chantelle style and the trim.
A little powder on the neck.
Right?
Watch a business simply for the weekend,
gentlemen.
Yeah,
thanks man.
Awesome.
As always there and the podcast is there.
I'm doing it tonight.
If anybody's in Los Angeles up yet the bar Lou,
but she's seven o'clock.
There's nobody better suited to the improvisational aspects of a live podcast
format.
The way you're doing it,
then you,
you're,
you're the best.
No,
you're awesome.
I really enjoy your comedy.
I really enjoyed talking to you every time I have you on the flag.
It's a real treat.
It's really neat time,
my friend,
carte blanche,
open invitation.
I don't even know what carp launch means.
Stuffs white card.
You got a white card,
sir.
Shouldn't try say carte blanche.
Like I'm smart when I couldn't write it.
I prefer a diner's club and I thank you.
Could not ever.
Greg Proops,
ladies and gentlemen,
follow him on Twitter.
Greg Proops on Twitter.
Greg proops.com is the website.
The special is called live at.
Lucille and frank can't get any better than that bitches.
Uh,
thanks also to our sponsors.
Thanks to Tim,
go to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks off of a new device.
Thanks also to audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Joe and say,
Yo owe us some money and get a free audio book in 33 days of honorable service.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o and n I t use the code word save 10% off
any and all Saba men's March 14th.
I will be in grand prairie,
Texas just outside of Dallas son and at the Verizon theater with Ari Shaffir and
Duncan Trussell.
That's right.
Bitches.
I'm not fucking around.
Go to Joe rogan.net for all dates and details and desk squad.tv for all of Brian
red bands,
upcoming comedy gigs,
lots of shit happening in the world of little Brian.
Yeah.
Portland,
Seattle and Vancouver for 18 four 19 four 20 and squad.tv.
Go there and check it out.
My podcasts and I was on iTunes.
Dysentery,
the sexual harassments.
Me.
Yeah.
If you really want to get angry at Brian,
download these podcasts.
All right,
we will see you.
We got a great group of spa of a podcast guests.
Next week we got a Greg Fitzsimmons.
We got um,
Jesus Christ.
Who else is a coming out?
Oh,
a Dunkin and Chris Ryan.
We're doing our threesome podcast.
Uh,
we're doing that on Tuesday though.
We've been,
the response has been insane for those podcasts.
So we've,
we've all committed to one a month.
One m w I'm doing,
we're doing mine this time.
Next time we do Dunkin's and then we do Chris Ryan's and we keep going in this
loop.
So,
uh,
I think that'll turn people on to two really great podcasts.
Duncan trussell's a family hour,
and Christopher Ryan's a tangentially speaking.
It should be the Christopher Ryan show.
I'm s I don't want complication,
man.
Why you fucking with my head man?
But that's going to be fun to talk to those guys next week.
Uh,
lots of other great guests coming up too.
We've got lots of fun stuff.
So see you guys soon.
And,
uh,
that's it.
Big Kiss.
Enjoy your weekend.